Nobunaga ich bin nur다가 was contains wenn zwei
Esther
ist
또
ELIMINES, SIMILAR D D
Da bin ich.
Das Leben ist hart.
Unter anderem bei den chinesischen China-Chinesen kaufen wir einen, genau.
Aber unter anderem, ich hab ein paar Sachen, muss ich mal gucken.
Was davon bei...
Was davon bei Aliexpress gibt.
Ihr werdet es nicht glauben, Leute.
Was ich gerade für eine Mail bekommen hab, Sponsoring-Anfrage.
Ihr kommt nicht drauf, nie im Leben.
Chat, ratet mal.
Ne, ne, jetzt noch hatten wir schon mal.
Raid Shadow Legends, genau.
Die Leute wissen es.
Sponsored Raid Shadow Legends Promotion.
Von...
Irgendjemand, den ich nicht aussprechen kann vom Namen... Jal... Koizor.
Das ist bestimmt Poggers.
Poggers, Leute.
So.
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Wollen wir mal gucken, was die so rausrücken für Raid Shadow Legends.
Also.
Hi Wupplochz, Wupplochz.
Ich kann doch nicht meinen Namen richtig schreiben, lul weh, Alter.
Okay.
Hope you are doing well.
I'm reaching out in regards to a sponsorship opportunity Raid Shadow Legends.
Deployed by StreamElements.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass StreamElements was damit zu tun haben.
Okay.
So, also.
Was die wollen.
Also, passt mal auf.
Was, was, was die...
Die wollen...
Requirements.
Zwei Stunden Sponsored Gameplay.
Am besten mit oder am Ende vom Stream, dass schon vorher richtig viel Viewership da ist.
Man ist klar, wenn einer mit Raid Shadow Legends startet, schaltet der Kassau ein.
Dann muss ich auf zwei...
Das steht da wirklich drin.
Ich muss auf zwei Trailer reacten.
Während dem Stream.
Wahrscheinlich kriege ich dann auch die Trailer vorgegeben, auf die ich zu reacten habe zu Raid Shadow Legends.
Und wahrscheinlich auch was ich sagen darf und was nicht.
So.
Ähm.
Dann, dann irgendwie einen Tracking Link, äh, Overlay.
Raid Shadow Legends Overlay on Stream.
Chatbot mit Raid Shadow Legends Tracking Link.
Und ein Twitter Post, Social Media, before going live mit Raid Shadow Legends Link.
Die wollen es, die wollen es aber echt wissen jetzt hier.
Okay, was gibt's denn da für?
Zeig mal her.
Also, was gibt's denn, was gibt's denn für Money?
Was gibt's, was gibt's denn da für eine Kohle für?
Zeig mal, wo, wo schreibe sind das denn?
Wo...
Oh, Sekunde, Sekunde.
Easy Money, wo steht's denn?
Okay, sie stellen mir alle Sachen zur Verfügung, die ich für den Stream brauche.
Das wäre noch schöner, wenn ich ein eigenes Raid Shadow Legends Overlay anfertigen müsste, ja.
Ähm.
Also, Base Pay sind 500 Dollar minus 15 Prozent.
Hä?
Was soll mir das denn sagen?
Base Pay, 500 Dollar minus 15 Prozent.
Hä?
Okay, was auch immer.
Ähm, so, okay, es geht weiter, es geht weiter, okay.
Ähm.
Die meinen plus 15 Prozent.
Glaube ich, nicht minus.
Okay, was auch immer, ich verstehe es nicht, ich verstehe es nicht, was, was die wollen.
So.
Und das increase um 45 Prozent, minus 15 Prozent, was auch immer die mir damit sagen wollen, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ähm, wenn...
Das ist, das ist, Leute, Leute, es ist so, es ist so, ich check's nicht.
Es ist so geschrieben, dass ich es ernsthaft nicht verstehe, was die wollen.
Dann stelle ich schreiben, dann zwischendrin noch irgendwas.
If you and Dollar 900 von Dollar 1.350 members of your community reach level 100.
Ja, aber warum Dollar und warum 900 von 1.350, was zum Teufel wollen die von mir, es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Kann das sein, dass da eine Variable drinstehen soll und dieses E-Mail-Programm von denen hat die Variable nicht richtig eingesetzt?
Dass da irgendein Prozent drinsteht?
Dass da irgendein Prozent drinsteht? Oder so?
Hm.
Oh, oh, beautiful deal structure, oh ja, alles klar, ich bin schon komplett...
Mysterium, Dankeschön für 500 Subscription.
Ich bin schon echt super überzeugt, weil Channel Legends Sponsoring hier zu machen.
Also, es steht dann irgendwas von 1.350 Dollar, ich weiß aber nicht, ob die wirklich Dollar meinen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, beautiful, wisst ihr, was beautiful daran ist?
Wenn ich öfters Raid Shadow Legends Werbung mache, dann zählt es zu den Leveln dazu.
Also, wenn ich jetzt ein Sponsoring mache und dann in zwei Wochen und ihr erreicht erst in zwei Wochen Level 100, dann kriege ich trotzdem Geld.
Bam!
Was ein Scheiß, Alter.
Ich werde dieses Spiel niemals zeigen, geschweige denn Spielen.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, also dieser Post ist so dermaßen schlecht geschrieben, dass du noch nicht mal verstehst, was die eigentlich von dir wollen.
Wahnsinn, echt Wahnsinn.
Raid Shadow Legends.
Keck, wait.
Na gut.
So, kannst du ein Jithub Tutorial machen, in dem, was, in einem der letzten Spiele hast du Git?
Hm, na gut.
Git MV hat mit Git Hub hier erst einmal nichts zu tun.
Git Hub ist ja nur ein Frontend.
Willst du ein Git Tutorial oder willst du ein Shit Hub Tutorial?
Ja ich mir auch, aber ich will diesen, ich gönn's denen nicht.
Ich gönn's Raid Shadow Legends nicht.
Beides machen, please.
Ein Shit Tutorial haben wir sogar schon mal vor Uhrzeiten gemacht, aber das war so eher aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt.
Manjaro, hier, guck da.
Ups, falsche VM.
Manjaro Linux, beste dafür.
Mehr als den Terminal und einen Browser brauchste da nicht drin, aber du siehst, es läuft wirklich wunderbar zackig.
Und wir haben sogar GLX Gears Max FPS am Start.
Also ich hab Manjaro sowohl in der VM mit I3 als auch auf meinem Notebook auf der Arbeit.
Passt wunderbar.
Ach so, by the way, ich sollte es vielleicht nochmal sagen, man spricht des nicht shit aus.
Nicht, dass ihr den gleichen Fehler macht wie der eine Azubi bei uns.
Ja, das muss nicht sein.
Kannst du mal ein Tutorial zu I3 machen? Nee, da braucht man kein Tutorial zu, das ist total easy.
Das ist gut vorkonfiguriert und du brauchst drei Shortcuts im Endeffekt.
Du brauchst Mod-Taste Enter für Terminal, du brauchst Mod-Taste 123 für Desktop wechseln.
Jo, das war's im Prinzip.
I3 ist das hier, diese Oberfläche, die du hier siehst.
Das Gute an der I3-Config ist, dass die relativ gut stollermäßig beschrieben ist, was was macht,
und dass die Default-Config vollkommen in Ordnung ist.
Du musst da eigentlich erstmal gar nichts umstellen.
So, also wie gesagt, I3 ist die Oberfläche, die ich hier verwende.
So, ok.
Oh, mal gucken Leute, geht das Pepega-Board eigentlich?
Leute, das Pepega-Board ist kaputt.
Moment, Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal testen.
Wo bloß? Test.
Pepega-Board ist kaputt.
Das geht nicht, warum nicht?
Hat Twitch die IRC-API abgestellt oder so?
Wartet mal.
Schreibt noch mal, add wo bloß, irgendwas.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Ok.
Also ich hab manjaro mit dem Aschitekt-Installer installiert,
und dann alles selbst installiert, das ist natürlich ein bisschen nerviger.
So sieht's aus, sehe ich genauso.
Ok, also, haben wir noch ein paar Questions bevor wir anfangen.
Irgendjemand habe ich hier was mit Kubuntu gelesen oder sowas.
Ja, hier, meine Freundin hat aktuell Kubuntu,
aber oft Bugs.
Ja, Ubuntu auf dem Desktop ist leider nicht das, was es mal war.
Meiner Meinung nach.
Also, ich weiß nicht, wie technikversiert deine Freundin ist.
Wenn es ähnlich zu Mac sein darf, dann elementary OS.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, Mädels gefällt elementary OS.
Ansonsten würde ich einfach Linux Mint nehmen,
da kannst du nicht allzu viel falsch machen, auch für Einsteiger.
Und wenn du was anderes ausprobieren willst,
was ich aber auch ganz gut fand für Einsteiger,
und du kein Problem damit hast, dass es eine China-Distribution ist,
dann nehm Deepin Linux, zumindest mal ausprobieren.
Die fand ich nämlich echt gut für das, was ich ausprobiert hab.
Aber es ist halt ein Chinesen-Linux, das muss einem halt klar sein.
Alternativ, ich weiß nicht, wenn deine Freundin Anime-Fan ist,
hätte ich auch was für dich zu bieten.
Dann, wie wäre es mit Mobuntu?
Dann kriegst du so hier eine Augenweite an Distribution.
Guck dir das mal an.
Viel besser geht es eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Also ich mein, das kann man schlecht noch toppen, muss man ehrlich mal sagen.
So, mal wieder aus.
Gut, schnell noch mal chat gucken.
Ja, was hast du installiert?
Wie gesagt, gerade GNOME-basierte Sachen sind extrem laggy,
oftmals in der VM.
Mobuntu geht auch, ja.
Aber ich mag Mint eigentlich ganz gern.
Aber am besten, was ist die Fault?
Cinnamon ist die Fault mittlerweile.
Also wenn ich nicht E3 verwenden würde, würde ich ehrlich gesagt
irgendwas XFCE-basiertes verwenden.
Oder Openbox.
Openbox habe ich früher auch verwendet.
Oder was, Fluxbox?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Das ist das ISO, wo nichts vorinstalliert ist.
Heute kaufen wir den Whirlpool, genau.
Das kannst du ausprobieren, das funktioniert nicht.
Hat noch keiner geschafft, zu injecten.
Wo hast du noch mal deine Vmware Workstation-Lizenz gekauft?
Bei Softwarekong.
Klingt sehr vertrauenserweckend, ja, ich weiß.
Warte mal, Leute, ich habe irgendwas übersehen, was ich noch beantworten wollte.
Was ich auf dem anderen Chat gelesen habe.
Welche Produkte von Shelley verwendest, das kann ich kurz zeigen.
Ich finde es immer noch fail, dass die Dinger switch to tap.
Moment, warum haben wir die noch offen hier?
Ah, weil das das PP-Gab, weil das die andere Vm ist.
Nee, nee, Moment, ich muss hier in die Vm.
Das ist die richtige Vm.
Shelley.
Also ich kann dir sagen, welche ich habe, und dann sage ich dir, welche ich verwende.
Verwenden tue ich davon ein paar.
Die habe ich auch schon am längsten.
Den habe ich hier liegen, habe ich noch nicht verwendet.
Habe ich aber auch vor.
Dann habe ich glaube noch ein Plak.
Einfach mal zum ausprobieren.
Irgendwann mal gekauft, habe ich aber auch nicht in Verwendung.
Also in Verwendung habe ich eigentlich nur die.
Den habe ich glaube ich auch mal gekauft zum ausprobieren.
Ich glaube davon habe ich auch noch mal ein Pak gekauft.
Aber die habe ich auch noch nicht eingebaut.
Nee, ich glaube ich habe wirklich nur davon welche in Benutzung.
ZDE 2586 POC, Huge Hyper Subscription hier.
Big Brain Sub.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Das habe ich gerade im Einsatz.
Aber mal Amazon auf.
So, hatte ich jetzt alles durch im Chat?
Bringt es richtig nice, wie viele Leute in letzter Zeit am Start sind.
Ob es nicht KegWade, Alter.
Postchamp.
Ich Postchamp.
Ich muss sagen, es zahlt sich halt immer aus, wenn man viel streben.
Ich habe in den letzten zwei Wochen relativ viel gestrieben.
Dann sind wieder viele Leute am Start.
Okay, POPO, es hat mir nicht gefallen.
Ja, korrekt.
Also Xfce Vm ist auch ziemlich gut.
Das passt, das passt sogar ziemlich gut dazu.
Mr. Xz, Twitch Prime Gaming, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich muss übrigens mal hier aufmachen, weil ich überlege, ich habe in letzter Zeit den Hangar zu Subs zu übersehen.
Aber ich glaube diesmal habe ich nichts übersehen.
So, Pool of Wish.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es das da gibt.
Warte mal, wir gucken mal auf Alibaba.
Nicht auf Alibaba, auf AliExpress.
AliExpress, ob es Hot Tubes gibt.
Hot Tubes.
Alter, was habe ich da jetzt angeklickt?
Gehst du fort.
Oder ein Apple Logo.
Meint ihr bei AliExpress auch, dass das echte legit Apple Sachen sind, die man da bekommt?
Ja.
Hot Tube.
Oh, exquisite.
Guck mal hier.
Classic Luxury, eine Badewanne kann ich mir bestellen bei AliExpress.
Jawoll.
Oder einen Whirlpool für 5000 Euro.
Ich glaube, den würde ich mir nicht.
Den würde ich mir nicht.
Was?
Was zum?
Moment.
Ist das für Mädels, dass die draußen pinkeln können wie ein Kerl?
Okay, das habe ich schon mal irgendwo gesehen bei einem anderen Shop.
Aber ich bin überrascht, dass AliExpress das bei Hot Tube bewirbt.
Ich habe bei AliExpress immer Angst, dass Monka Tossbilder drauf sind.
Whirlpool.
Oh, so viel gibt es da nicht.
Also ich kann mir eine Badewanne, eine Luxus Badewanne kaufen.
Titanium Floor Mound Shower.
Sieht das in irgendeiner Art und Weise?
Doch, da hängt eine Schauer.
Moment, man kauft nicht die Badewanne, man kauft die Dusche.
Man kauft gar nicht die Badewanne, das ist Jebait.
Man kauft die Dusche.
Haha, das ist ja Verarschung.
Massive Jebait von den China-Chinesen wieder, Alter.
Ach guck mal, das ist ja Deutschland.
Das dauert nur eineinhalb Monate.
Ne, Moment, zwei Monate das liefern zu lassen.
FedEx liefert das exquisite für 40 Euro.
Tja, also, oder ich kauf mir ernsthaft, ich kauf mir den Whirlpool.
What the fuck?
Sag mal, kann AliExpress mal in irgendeiner Art und Weise?
Sag mal, warum hat AliExpress zweimal die gleiche Suche
und dann zwei komplett unterschiedliche Ergebnisse?
Guckt euch das an.
Das ist die gleiche Suche, da gibt es komplett unterschiedliche Ergebnisse.
Okay, guck mal, hier kann ich mir den Whirlpool kauft.
Guck mal, die hat sogar schon zwei Stück.
Zwei Stück haben den Whirlpool bei AliExpress schon gekauft.
Jawoll, zwei Stück haben den schon gekauft, eine Bewertung.
Kundenbewertung, Logistics, EMS.
Ah, Cokomodates haben bestellt.
Ah, das wundert mich nicht.
Cokomodates am Start, alles klar.
Ich mein, gibt es wirklich, gibt es, er erkennt noch nicht mal, was das sein soll.
Gibt es wirklich Leute, die für 3000 Euro einen Whirlpool auf AliExpress bestellen?
Das kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Wenn ich 3000 Euro ausgebe, kriege ich doch hier wahrscheinlich auch schon irgendwas.
Was kosten hier einen Whirlpool?
Was kosten Whirlpool, wenn ich mir den kaufen will?
Sogar noch billiger, warum soll ich das bei AliExpress kaufen?
Aufblasbarer Whirlpool, hier.
Zeus Riesen Whirlpool.
Und hier gibt es einen für nur 13.000 Euro.
Und das ist der gleiche wie bei AliExpress.
Schwachsinn.
Naja, rauchen wir eh nicht.
So, also jetzt wollen wir ganz schnell den Chat fertig machen.
Also...
Wie hieß noch mal die Mikrotik-Switch, die dir empfohlen hast?
Das kann ich dir sagen, wenn du mir sagst, für was ich dir empfohlen habe.
Also den, den ich mir zuletzt gekauft habe, das ist der hier gewesen,
aber den würde ich gar nicht mal zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt so sehr empfehlen,
weil, ich meine, der steht hier, der steht immer noch da auf dem Basteltisch,
den habt ihr jetzt auch schon öfters mal gesehen,
wenn ich hier die Kamera angemacht habe beim Basteln.
Der Switch an sich ist echt cool.
Das Problem dabei ist, nur erst mal kurz, ich zeige euch mal die Features.
Mikrotik sollte mich übrigens auch mal sponsoren.
Du bekommst 8 Gigabit-Ports und 2 SFP-Plus-Ports.
SFP-Plus-Ports kannst du reinmachen, 1G, 2,5G, 5G und 10G,
je nachdem, was du für ein Modul reinmachst.
Aber, warum ich den Switch aktuell noch nicht empfehlen würde,
ist, weil die Firmware Hardcore sackt.
Und ich glaube, es gibt bis heute noch keine Firmware,
keine offizielles Firmware-Release.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit Mikrotik los ist.
Ich meine, wo ist denn die Logik, ich release eine Hardware
und ich habe noch keine Firmware dafür fertig.
Es hat einen Web GUI.
Es hat einen Web GUI, das ist das Switch OS.
Mal gucken, ob es eine Demo von Switch OS gibt.
Ich kann es nicht zeigen, weil ich habe es nicht an.
Ich kann das Web GUI zeigen.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz anschalten, Leute.
Ich kann es nicht zeigen.
So, ich zeige euch gleich das Webinterface, wenn das Ding gebootet ist.
Also, es hat einen Webinterface.
Kannst du auch über CLI konfigurieren, aber es ist halt unfertig,
wenn man sich die Firmware anguckt.
Also, es hat einen Webinterface.
Kannst du auch über CLI konfigurieren, aber es ist halt unfertig,
wenn man sich die Firmware anguckt.
Sobald es eine wirklich releasete Firmware gibt,
die keine großartigen Probleme mehr hat,
dann kann ich den Switch rein von der Hardware wirklich empfehlen.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass die Leute
in den inoffiziellen Forumthread müssen
und das nicht so einfach ist.
Das kann doch nicht sein, dass die Leute in den inoffiziellen Forumthread müssen
und sich dort dann irgendwelche
komischen
Beta-Firmwares runterladen müssen.
Ich finde übrigens den Thread mit der Firmware gar nicht.
CSS.
Ich weiß dann, was ich suchen muss und ich finde es noch nicht einmal.
Haben sie jetzt eine offizielle?
Wenn sie jetzt eine offizielle Firmware haben,
dann kann man sich das Ding tatsächlich kaufen.
Wo haben die das denn im Download?
Hier, SW, Twitch OS, CSS.
Nee.
Ach, hier, da.
Ach, guck mal, es gibt jetzt tatsächlich, es gibt eine Firmware.
Na, immerhin, immerhin.
So, ich gucke mal kurz nach rechts, kann euch das Webinterface zeigen.
Muss ich das nur mal kurz raussuchen.
Wenn ich das finde.
Muss ich mal mal einen DHCP gucken.
Mikrotik.
Der müsste es sein.
Ja, der müsste es sein.
So wie ich mich kenne, ist es admin123456.
Oh fuck, jetzt habe ich ein Problem.
Was habe ich da für ein Passwort-Knopf?
Das weiß ich doch jetzt immer.
Was ist denn der Standard-User bei Mikrotik?
Ist es admin?
Admin no Passwort.
Ah, admin no Passwort, easy.
Okay, ich habe gar kein Passwort vergeben.
Also, so sieht das Webinterface aus.
Ich mache mal kurz Darkreader raus.
Du kannst halt nicht allzu viel machen,
aber du hast ein Managed Webinterface, wo du so Sachen machen kannst,
wie VLANs vergeben und Port Aggregation und sonstige Geschichten.
Aber wir müssen mal kurz Upgrade gucken.
System.
Oh, mal mal Firmware-Update, wo geht das?
Firmware-Update, das ist zu big brain, ich finde es noch nicht immer.
Upgrade.
Hier, ich habe zwei Brings, latest available version.
Download and upgrade.
Updaten wir das Ding jetzt.
Please do not interrupt.
Gleich haben wir den Switch geprägt.
Mal gucken, ob es halt anders aussieht.
Tja, also das könnte ich jetzt tatsächlich,
also wenn die Firmware released ist,
ging auch relativ schnell,
wenn die Firmware released ist
und die jetzt tatsächlich die meisten Probleme behebt,
dann kann ich dir den empfehlen,
weil wie gesagt, ihr bekommt zwei SF4 Plus Ports
für 1, 2,5, 5 und 10G,
ich habe da ein 10G Modul drinne
und Kupfer Ports 1G, 8 Stück.
Das ist preisleistungsmäßig wirklich unschlagbar,
weil das Ganze kostet, glaube ich, nur 85 Euro.
Ja, bla, das zählt.
Hier müsst ihr gucken.
85, 90 Euro, das ist wirklich nice.
Das ist wirklich nice.
Und du kannst hier schon
ein bisschen advancede Sachen mitmachen.
Psst.
Seht ihr,
du kannst hier schon
ein bisschen advancede Sachen mitmachen.
Du kannst Ports zusammenfassen zu...
Du kannst keine Ahnung,
irgendwie 4Gigabit Ports zusammenpassen
zu einem 4Gigabit Port.
Du kannst, was auch immer das sein soll,
ich habe keinen Plassen Schimmer.
Tja, im Prinzip brauchen wir
wahrscheinlich nur die WLAN-Settings,
sonst nichts großartig.
Ja.
Zumindest ist hier die WLAN-Config
einfacher als unter RouterOS.
Die RouterOS-Einstellung für WLANs
ist echt komplett cancer.
SNMP, falls irgendwie einer
SNMP-Monitoring daheim war,
ich glaube es wäre eher nett.
Ja, das war es.
Also es hält sich im Vergleich zu RouterOS
durchaus in Grenzen, was das Ding kann.
Es ist halt ein Switch und es ist RouterOS-Lite.
Aber für 85 Euro ist der Switch wirklich gut,
da kannst du nichts sagen.
Welchen Router hast du?
Ich habe einen Hex-POE.
So ein Teil.
Sechs Ports,
fünf Ports Kupfer,
einen SFP-Port.
Kann man aber auch
auf einen R45-Adapter reinmachen.
Der ist echt gut.
Das ist zum Beispiel ganz praktisch,
dass der POE hat,
weil ich habe meine zwei
Access Points dran per POE.
Ich habe hier zwei Unify-Access Points.
Du musst nur drauf gucken,
dass das funktioniert.
Du musst den Router
mit einem 48 Volt-Netzteil betreiben,
sonst geht das nicht.
Weil die gleiche Spannung,
mit der der Router betrieben wird,
benutzt er für POE.
Also die haben da keine großartigen
Spannungswandler oder sowas drin.
Also wenn du beispielsweise
Access Points,
die POE brauchen, betreiben willst,
dann musst du halt an den Router
einen 48 Volt-Netzteil anschließen.
Aber da gibt es genug von.
Ja.
Preis-Leistung ist beim Mikrotip top.
Cisco ist halt benutzerfreundlicher.
Ja, Cisco ist halt benutzerfreundlicher,
wenn man sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnt hat
und auch insgesamt
ist das Handling doch angenehmer.
So, also, hatten wir.
Danke schon für den Sub.
Habe ich schon vorgelesen,
aber 14 Monate
ist Massive Hyper-Subscription.
Ja, die Shellies sind richtig cool.
Vor allem, weil man
den Kram nicht flaschen muss.
Man kann den zwar flaschen,
aber deswegen finde ich nach wie vor
richtig fail, dass Shelley
als Domain Shelley.cloud hat.
Das Hauptverkaufsargument
von den Shelley-Dingern
ist ehrlich gesagt, ja,
dass die keine Cloud brauchen.
Aber, was auch immer.
BigBrain-Domain.
Berger Games.
Twitch Prime-Subscription.
Danke schon für den Sub.
Huge IQ Boost wieder hier.
So.
Das stimmt, wir haben
einige stille Zuschauer,
aber die sind regelmäßig am Start.
Wie gesagt, ich finde es immer geil,
wenn ich teilweise Leute
wieder subscriben sehe,
die schon irgendwie zwei Jahre
oder so am Start sind oder länger.
Mo Ubuntu heißt das.
Guck, wenn du,
wenn du dir das installieren willst,
dann gehst du hier
Mo Ubuntu suchst du
und dann gehst du da hin
und lädst dir das Theme runter
und dann hast du
Massive Ayaya Ubuntu-Theme.
Nein, habe ich noch nie installiert,
habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Preis-Jump ist bei Hetzner gehostet.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind,
Leute, soll ich noch mal
eine Runde Hetzner-Sellout machen?
Ja, komm, scheiß drauf.
Die Hauptsache,
die Statistiken sehen gut aus.
Wir machen jetzt noch mal kurz
eine Runde Hetzner-Sellout,
wo wir gerade schon mal dabei sind.
Also, falls ihr mein letztes Video
nicht gesehen habt
und ihr mal
die Hetzner-Cloud ausprobieren wollt,
da könnt ihr über den Link hier,
den ich jetzt gleich in den Chat poste,
könnt ihr hingehen
und wenn ihr euch angemeldet habt,
könnt ihr dann in der Konsole,
steht ja hier alles drinne,
in der Cloud-Konsole
gebt ihr den Code ein
und dann bekommt ihr 20 Euro Guthaben
und was man mal
mit diesem 20 Euro Guthaben
machen kann,
kann ich euch auch zeigen.
Ihr könnt euch zum Beispiel
für drei Monate lang
fast, fast
einen 3-Core,
fast einen Triple-Core-VM kaufen
oder ihr könnt euch zum Beispiel
das Ding holen für,
also, man kann da schon
ein bisschen was mit machen
mit 20 Euro Startguthaben.
Ich meine, die kleinste VM
kostet aktuell 3 Euro,
das schwankt immer ein bisschen
je nach Tag,
aber 20 Euro ist zum Ausprobieren
wirklich top.
Oh, guck mal,
ich kann meinen Link nicht kopieren.
Was ist denn hier los?
Warum kann ich meinen,
warum darf ich meinen Link
nicht kopieren?
Okay, dann kopiere ich den so.
Exzellent.
Könnt ihr draufklicken,
könnt euch einloggen.
Geht allerdings, wie gesagt,
nur für Neukunden.
Also, wenn ihr da schon angemeldet seid,
dann müsst ihr euch überlegen,
was ihr macht.
Hetzner ist, weiß ich nicht,
ob die so erfreut sind
über zweite Couts,
keine Ahnung.
Sollen mir aber auch egal sein.
Da könnt ihr euch zumindest anmelden
und in der Cloud-Konsole
den Kram einlösen.
So, und da hoste ich übrigens
auch den Preis-Champ.
Wen das interessiert,
der Preis-Champ, der läuft,
also das Ding,
der in Okuma Alternate
hat hier Exquisite
für einfach nur doppelten UVP-Preis
aktuell 3.790.
Exzellent.
Ein wahrer Schnapper.
Also der...
Also der Preis-Champ,
der läuft aktuell
mit 3 Stück davon,
äh,
einer davon
und einer davon.
Also es sind insgesamt 5 VMs.
Das sind die Crawler,
die die Shops updaten,
da sind es 3 Stück.
Das hier ist aktuell das Frontend,
reicht in Dual-Core-Kiste
locker aus
und das hier ist so ein
Analytics-Server,
der aber keine Benutzersachen
aufzeichnet,
weil sonst DSG-VO,
ihr wisst ja.
So sieht's aus.
Also ich hab da ja auch nicht
die Wahnsinns-Ausgaben für.
Am Anfang hatte ich
eine superfette 16-Core-Kiste
zum Testen,
aber das hat sich nicht gelohnt.
So.
Äh, das ist eine gute Idee.
Können wir mal ein Ausrufezeichen,
äh,
BigBrain-Mod-Team am Start,
können wir ein
ein Ausrufezeichen
Hetzner-Command machen,
wo der Link drin steht?
Warum braucht man da
so viele VMs?
Äh, bietet sich an in dem Fall.
Eine fürs Frontend,
drei für die Crawler
und eine Analytics-Kiste,
die man für alles andere
auch verwenden kann.
Die kommen sich auch nicht in die Quere,
machen die Crawler beispielsweise
nicht komplette CPU-Dicht.
Vorher hatte ich auf einer 16-Core-Kiste
mit, äh, Docker
und, äh,
CPU-Beschränkungen laufen.
Das hat aber andere Probleme gemacht.
So.
Ich komm, glaub ich,
nie mehr zum Einkaufen.
Der Chat ist
Massive-Active.
Ich, ich benutze übrigens
Arch-Linux, by the way,
falls ihr's noch nicht mitgekriegt habt.
Oh Mist, jetzt hab ich das
Black-Facing-Emote verwendet.
Anzeige ist raus.
Toss.
Alter.
Das hab ich ja immer noch im Board.
Keg-Wait.
Das ist ja verpönt mittlerweile.
Band.
Ja, genau.
Nein, die Lieferung
bleibt nicht beim Zoll hängen.
Das ist das Gute an den
chinesischen China-Shops.
Die bleiben nicht im Zoll hängen,
weil die Chinesen
machen das richtig.
Die schicken das entweder
über die Niederlande,
dann ist es von der EU nach EU,
also kein Problem,
oder sie schicken es über Spanien,
dann ist es auch von EU nach EU,
oder sie haben einen Warenlager
und schicken es gleich
von EU nach EU.
Das Einzige, wo du Pech hast
mit dem Zoll ist,
wenn du den
aller, aller, aller billigsten
Versandweg nimmst
und die chinesen,
chinesischen Shops
nicht wissen, wie es geht
und es 48 Tage unterwegs ist
und irgendwie direkt an dich
adressiert mit dem Schiff kommt,
dann langen sie es vielleicht
beim Zoll,
aber sonst machen die Chinesen
das richtig
und es landet eigentlich
so gut wie nie beim Zoll.
Kann man das anklicken
oder ist das Rickrolled?
Nee.
Das hatten wir doch.
Das hatten wir doch gestern.
Du musst,
du musst beim Booten
Display Drive gleich Mesa
einstellen.
Ja, warte mal.
Ich guck mal in meine History.
Mesa.
Hier, Driver gleich Mesa
musst du einstellen.
Beim Booten.
Da steht Driver gleich Free
und das musst du überschreiben
mit Driver gleich Mesa.
Dann funktioniert es.
Moment, das hatten wir schon.
Tja, nee, weiß ich auch nicht.
Vor allem bei Tools installieren
auf jeden Fall, ne?
Also, vor allem bei Workstation
funktioniert in dem Fall
auch deutlich besser
als Virtual Box
und du musst vor allem bei Tools installieren
inklusive der ganzen X-Server-Gedöns.
Hast du Clipboard-Manager laufen?
Ja, hab ich.
Ich habe laufen.
Green Clip, glaube ich.
Green Clip mit der Rufi-Extension.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist ganz praktisch.
Da kannst du das hier nämlich
auch durchsuchen, deine History.
Richt Spock.
Wenn du dann was aus der History brauchst,
aus deiner Clipboard-History,
klickst du an,
kannst gleich einfügen.
Eigentlich recht nice.
Passwort-Leak.
Oh, was hab ich wieder geleakt, Leute?
Wo hab ich mein Passwort geleakt?
Ist doch gar kein Passwort drin hier.
Jebaited.
Chat.
Warum macht ihr so was immer?
Warum jebaitet ihr mich immer?
Der Chat macht das immer,
weil ich critical information lecke.
Was zum Teufel sind Aguilators?
Warum hab ich Aguilators,
bitteschön, in der Clipboard-History?
Aguilators.
Das hier ist, by the way,
auch kein Passwort.
Das sind irgendwelche kopierten Zeichen.
Okay.
Ja, Mikrotik ist ultra nice.
Achtest du auf Kabeldurchmesser,
die zum Beispiel LEDs an Netzteilen anschließt
oder so?
Ja, mittlerweile schon.
Nachdem ich mir mal fast die Finger
verbrannt habe im Stream,
falls ich da noch einer dran erinnern kann,
weil ich eine 5-Volt-LED-Strip
mit 10 Ampere betrieben hab.
Mit einem Minikabel.
Und falls sich da noch einer dran erinnert.
Seitdem achte ich auf Kabeldurchmesser.
Hab ich schon gezeigt.
Was geht es hier um Sponsoring-Geschichten?
Zeig mal.
Was ist hier die Diskussion?
Mikrotik, sponsor dich mal.
Ja, die sollen mich mal gefällig
sponsoren bei Mikrotik.
Ich könnte ja Reverse-Sponsoring machen.
Also sprich, anstatt dass Mikrotik mich anschreibt,
schreibe ich einfach Mikrotik an
mit einem schlechten Übersetzer auf Polnisch.
Die kommen doch aus Polen, oder?
Kommen die nicht aus Polen, Mikrotik?
Lettland, Lettland.
Ach du Scheiße, was spricht man denn in Lettland?
Sprache.
Lettisch.
Ach du große Scheiße.
Ok, ok, ich muss mal kurz Google Translator.
Also wir probieren das jetzt mal kurz aus.
German, Deutsch nach Lettisch.
Also Hallo Mikrotik.
Labdien.
Das klingt aber auch schon fast gekommunert.
Hallo Mikrotik, wollt ihr mich sponsoren?
Labdien Mikrotik, wei tu veljes mani sponsoret?
Alles klar.
Ich würde sagen, Sponsorship ist auf dem Weg.
Direkt raus.
Auch bevor ich das abschiege.
Lass sie sprechen.
Ok, wartet mal.
Moment, das muss ich aber, das kann ich nicht in der vm machen.
Also ich, ok, ok.
Ich lass es aussprechen.
Alles klar.
Lettisch.
Das ist eine Hallo Mikrotik, wollt ihr mich sponsoren?
Labdien Mikrotik, wei tu veljes mani sponsoret?
Ah, klingt, könnte auch russisch sein.
Kann ich, ich bin Triggert, ich möchte gerne einen weiblichen Sprecher haben.
Geht nicht, oder?
Wie kann ich, wie kann ich die Sprache ändern?
Die Stimme.
Geht das?
Labdien Mikrotik, wei tu veljes mani sponsoret?
Alles klar.
Und jetzt ganz wichtig, wie klingt es auch französisch?
Bonjour Mikrotik, veux tu me parrainer?
Ah, yes, yes, oui, oui.
Ist das Terraria Musik?
Nein, das ist Mario Kart Musik.
Womit könnte ich denn gut VLANs einrichten?
Die Fritzbox kann sowas nicht.
Ja, zum Beispiel mit so einer Mikrotik-Switch.
Oder mit jedem, eigentlich mit fast jedem etwas besseren Switch.
Ach, so ist es in deinem Keypass, nip.
Aber es war ja gar kein Passwort, es war ja einfach Enter drücken.
Der hat auch eine CLI, der Switch, ja.
Glaube ich zumindest.
RouterOS hat eine CLI.
Gute Frage, ob der auch eine CLI hat.
Hat er eine CLI?
Zwei Punkt, hat er eine CLI?
Normalerweise ist da oben ein CLI-Knopf.
Hat der SSH Zugang?
S-W-O-S, hat der?
Okay, nee, der hat kein CLI.
Der hat kein CLI, der hat anscheinend nur Weaponterfaces.
Das wusste ich auch nicht.
Okay, nur Weaponterfaces.
CLI-Switch mit ein KLI, ja.
Man macht vieles.
Das erinnert mich an die Call of Duty-Videos früher.
Max, da spricht man Cobra aus und nicht Codra.
Was für eine Firewall benutzt die, die in dem Router eingebaut ist?
Die Standard-IP-Filter-Firewall, die im Hex-POE drin ist.
What the fuck?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das stimmt nicht.
Ja, ist sehr laut, easy.
War das nicht so ein ausgedienter RZ-Switch,
der auch relativ laut ist und Strom verbraucht?
Ist er? Ja, kann sein, nur flickt er an den Seiten.
Ja, sobald der Crawler aktualisiert wird, schon.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Magst du Katzen? Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommen könnte.
Aber in Wirklichkeit mag ich keine Katzen.
Ich habe zwar Katzen-Emotes, aber nee.
Doch, doch, klar.
Ich habe hier nicht umsonst eine.
Kann man Agile und Diagonal skalieren?
In der Magenta-Cloud? Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Diagonal skalieren ist in der Magenta-Cloud, geht das nicht.
Diagonal skalieren kann man vielleicht mit einem Stadia-Account oder so,
aber nicht in der Magenta-Cloud, das funktioniert nicht.
So, also, kommen wir heute nochmal irgendwo anfangen, zeig mal her.
Schaust du eigentlich auch über die Shops Saturn im Media-Markt, wenn es da was gibt?
Bist du auf Windows und Linux gleichzeitig?
Korrekt, hier ist man Windows, hier ist man Linux.
Der ist wirklich praktisch, ist auch easy zu installieren.
Okay, ich glaube, jetzt habe ich gleich alles.
Das kann ich dir sagen, was du da machen musst.
Ich sollte Consulting-Geld verwenden mittlerweile.
Du musst das hier installieren.
MM, wie heißt das?
Wait a minute.
Warum geht das nicht?
Ping.
Jetzt geht es.
Das musst du installieren.
Und natürlich das Vmware-Zeug starten, aber für Clipboard musst du den Kram installieren.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal ein Update machen, hier nebenbei, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Exquisite Update.
Oh ja, vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich das Katzen-Emote so rein mache.
So ein Chico-Emote bräuchte man eigentlich schon.
Und das hat er ja auch ganz gut ausgeschnitten hier.
Ist Hetzner agil?
Agil genug.
Agile.
Hyper Agile.
Die machen bestimmt auch viel Daily-Scrums und haben ein Kanban-Board.
Da kann eigentlich nichts mehr schiefgehen.
Wenn sie dann auch Save und Team-Shape-Teams anwenden, dann ist eigentlich alles in Butter.
So.
Gut, also, ich bin jetzt im Chat durch.
Dann können wir jetzt mal anfangen einzukaufen, würde ich sagen.
Bam, in your face.
Wo habe ich meine Massive-Einkaufsliste?
Irgendwo habe ich die hier am Start, zeige ich dir mal her.
By the way, ich habe übrigens noch eine gute Idee.
Ich habe übrigens noch eine gute Idee, das muss ich mal den Hetzner-Leuten vorschlagen.
Weil es wird ja immer im Stream gefragt, wie ich das mache, dass ich Lokal-Zertifikate verwende.
Na, ihr habt das ja schon öfters gesehen, wenn ich beispielsweise hier auf mein Dashboard gehe.
Dann hat es ein gültiges Zertifikat.
Und ich habe ja schon öfters erklärt, dass ich habe eine eigene Domain, mache Let's Encrypt und sonst wie.
Ich habe mir gedacht, man könnte echt mal einen Stream machen, wo man das wirklich mit so wenig Zwischenschritten
und so wenig Magic macht wie geht, sodass man vielleicht mal versteht, wie der ganze Kram funktioniert.
Also sprich, wir würden uns ein Domain machen.
Wir würden dann den DNS von Hand, den Key hinterlegen und mit Zertifikat machen.
Das dauert jetzt zwar nicht lang, aber dann sieht man wenigstens mal, wie das funktioniert und was das macht.
Weil wenn man so Sachen wie Traffic verwendet oder irgendwelche fertigen Zertifikat-Skript oder sonst was,
dann geht das zwar auch alles, aber ist ultra-magic und keiner versteht es.
Was für ein Notebook nutzt du bei der freien, ja es gibt freie OS-Wahl, zumindest bisher.
Sie sind jetzt gerade so auf dem Trip, sie wollen uns Windows vorschreiben, wo ich ja absolut kein Fan von bin.
Und wir haben auch lange genug gemeckert, das heißt wir bekommen zumindest alle weiterhin Linux VMs.
Und ich habe aktuell noch einen Manjaro mit I3 installiert auf meinem Notebook
und bis mir das einer aus der Hand reißt, werde ich das auch nicht ändern.
Es sei denn, jemand schaltet es aus, nimmt es mir ab oder sonst wie, der mir was zu sagen hat.
Oder gibt mir die Anweisung explizit dazu, das nicht mehr zu verwenden und ich habe halt die Möglichkeit, was anderes zu nehmen.
Also mal gucken.
Bei uns wird, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch auf der Arbeit ist, aber bei uns wird immer ganz viel Wind um nichts gemacht.
Also dann soll das kommen, eine Woche später soll das kommen, zwei Wochen später soll das kommen.
Und wenn ihr dann mal einen Monat abwartet, kommt vielleicht von zehn Sachen, die angekündigt werden, eins.
Also das Beste, was man bei uns auf der Arbeit machen kann, ist in der Regel einfach mal drei, vier Wochen warten,
wenn was Neues angekündigt wird oder wenn was Neues angekündigt wird oder angekündigt wurde.
Und wenn es nach drei Wochen noch aktuell ist, dann kann man sich da Gedanken drüber machen.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, weil die erzählen so viel, wenn der Tag lang ist, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Was ist denn das für ein Dashboard? Oh, ich glaube, das habe ich noch nie gezeigt, das Dashboard.
Sollte ich vielleicht auch mal vorstellen hier im Stream. Stop, Chat, das Dashboard habt ihr noch nie gesehen, ne?
Dankeschön für den Sub. Paff, fick, ku. Wie auch immer, wenn man das ausspricht.
Huge IQ Subscription.
WSLG probiere ich vielleicht mal sogar bei uns auf der Arbeit dann aus, wenn ich einen Windows Notebook kriege.
Du dürftest theoretisch auch Temple OS nehmen, wenn du damit ordentlich arbeiten könntest, aber ich bezeichne es mal.
Unrun Dead, Stufe 1. Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Ja, doch. Gibt schon ein paar. Mein Chef hat mir was zu sagen, mein Abteilungsleiter hat mir was zu sagen.
Also in dem Fall mein Teamleiter hat mir was zu sagen, mein Abteilungsleiter hat immer was zu sagen.
Also, was kommt als nächstes? Bereichsvorstand oder so kommt als nächstes, glaube ich, hat mir was zu sagen.
Und der Vorstand hat mir natürlich auch was zu sagen. Also doch, doch, da gibt es schon genug, die mir was sagen können.
Ist das da auch so?
Okay, nice. Okay, ich habe den Chat geschafft. Auf geht's. Also, exquisite Attacke einkaufen hier.
Sarah Lombardy, neues Album.
Jetzt ist Sarah Lombardy.
Die ist doch bestimmt noch in der Castingshow, oder?
Na, juckt mich auch ehrlich gesagt null.
So, also, Moment. Was wollte ich denn jetzt einkaufen? Ich muss mal meine Liste suchen, kurz.
Du wolltest das Dash... Leute, das ist doch nur so, das ist doch nur Dashboard Meme. Ich zeige das Dashboard doch jedes Mal.
Jedes Mal im Stream für meine Heizung, ja?
Das ist ein Dashboard für die Heizung, wo ich beispielsweise sehe, dass meine Heizung gerade Wassertemperatur hat.
Von 54 Grad im Kessel, dass der Brenner gerade aktiv ist. Kessel Temperatur auf 48 Grad ist, das heißt es heizt gerade nicht.
Abgas Temperatur ist, das heißt es heizt gerade nicht. Aber was warm ist, wird gerade gepumpt.
Das bedeutet wahrscheinlich irgendwie Heizkörper an. So.
Exzellent, exzellent. So, wo habe ich denn jetzt meine Einkaufsliste?
Also.
Wisst ihr womit ich, das muss ich euch jetzt mal kurz zeigen, wisst ihr womit ich echt liebäugle mir was zu kaufen?
Ich hadere aber noch so ein bisschen mit mir.
Kennt ihr diesen Channel? Der testet Staubsauger.
Der testet zum Beispiel solche Dinger hier.
Wo er irgendwie über den Boden, über den Boden rollt und Zeugs auf Hallo YouTube please.
Vodafone.
Postchamp.
Vodafone, was ist da wieder los?
Droppen wir irgendwelche Frames oder so? Null Frames droppt.
Habe ich irgendwie großartige Auslastung oder ist einfach die Verbindung zu Vodafone gerade wieder die Vodafone verbinden?
Ah, jetzt gehts.
Okay.
Oh, ich hab noch vor einmal laufen, bei mir auf dem anderen Rechner kann das sein.
Ja.
Ah, super.
So, also der zeigt dann solche komischen Dinger und der hat letztens was getestet.
Da bin ich am überlegen ob ich mir sowas kaufen soll, warte mal ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Da bin ich am überlegen ob ich mir sowas kaufen soll.
Weil das coole ist, weil das coole ist, das Ding ist quasi nochmal ein Staubsauger für den Staubsauger.
Also sprich, der Staubsauger fährt rum, fährt dann in die Basisstation und die Basisstation saugt den Staubsauger aus.
Also er wird richtig viel gesackt.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor, ich spule mal ein bisschen vor wenn er das zeigt.
Aber ich finde den Ansatz her von einem Staubsauger haben das nicht alle Sauger, nein es gibt ganz wenige, es gibt ganz wenige die sowas haben, das ist auch relativ neu.
Ja, also sprich das Ding, also das ist wohl ein guter, also wo zeigt er das denn mit der Basisstation, das ist halt richtig nice mit der Base.
Ja genau hier fährt das Ding dann drauf, guck hier, der ist jetzt fertig, sauber machen und dann fährt er an die Dockingstation und die Dockingstation hat hier oben drin einen Müllbeutel und saugt den dann aus.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache oder?
Ich bin noch einmal überlegen ob ich mir das holen soll.
Das Problem ist, dass der Kram in Deutschland mal wieder übelst teuer ist.
Da braucht man ja doch wieder einen Beutel, ne was brauchst du denn sonst?
Also ich meine ob du jetzt das jedes Mal ausleerst und den Mülleimer schmeißt oder ob du einmal im Monat den Beutel leer machst und den Mülleimer schmeißt, das ist mit dem Beutel doch deutlich angenehmer als das jedes Mal zu machen.
Achso du meinst dass die quasi den Mülleimer machen.
Ich glaube den Flaschen die leider noch nicht, es gibt wohl irgendwie Trick 17, dass man den zumindest mit Home Assistant betreiben kann, aber ich glaube es gibt noch keine Möglichkeit ihn rein lokal zu steuern, das ist ja auch das was mich ehrlich gesagt davon abhält bis jetzt.
Also können ich den Flaschen oder den rein lokal steuern, hätte ich ihn mir schon gekauft, aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock auf einen Cloud Staubsauger.
Mein Katz wird da nicht in die Nähe gehen.
Ja ich guck ob der noch was zeigt zur Basis Station.
Ja gut dass das Ding wischen kann juckt mich nicht, das kann meiner auch und das benutze ich nie.
Ja und das Problem ist dass der Scheiß halt viel zu teuer ist, dass ich mir nicht sicher bin ob ich ihn wirklich haben will. Würde das jetzt 300 Euro kosten, hätte ich mir ihn schon bestellt.
Das ist übrigens der falsche N8 Pro, das geht dann eher so in Richtung 500 Euro.
Hier 600 Euro beim Media Markt.
Also ich denke mal wenn man was Gutes findet bekommt man den bestimmt auch für 500 Euro, aber 500 Euro für nicht genau wissen ob ich den eigentlich wirklich haben will ist halt...
Ja oder?
600 oder gar 600 Euro ist halt Paynes Champ.
So teuer ist der Aufpreis gar nicht, also wenn man sich andere anguckt ohne das also die richtig guten da bezahlst du auch 450 Euro für.
Warum ich mir diesen Staubsauger gekauft habe? Ja eigentlich nur weil ich das selbstlern geil finde.
Hier einen für 400, das bestimmt ein Rickroll Video, ne ist kein Rickroll Video. Wie gesagt ich habe hier selbst einen Roborock S5.
Aber nicht den Max den normalen also den S50 das ist der gleiche wie der S5.
Den habe ich damals glaube für 290 oder so gekauft, aber da war der noch relativ neu.
Wie oft musst du sonst den Beutel leeren?
Wie meinst du jetzt bei den aktuellen? Die haben ja kein Beutel die haben ja so ein Fach was man rausnimmt.
Das musst du nach jedem reinigen sauber machen.
Und je nachdem wie viel Dreck du hast musst du ihn vielleicht einmal im Monat machen oder vielleicht auch öfter hast du den Beutel bei dem mit selbst leeren.
Naja also wie gesagt ich bin am überlegen sobald man diese Dinger sobald es einen guten gibt den man rein lokal steuern kann bin ich dabei.
Easy, sofort gekauft.
Da musst du dir mal das Video von dem Typ angucken was ich eben gezeigt habe.
Der hat ja auch was explizit erzählt zu Haustierhaare.
Hast du keine Angst dass die Chinesen den Raumplan von dir klauen?
Nee, weil ich hab meinen geflasht. Guck hier da.
Mein Staubsauger Roboter sieht so aus. Hat eine Webinterface lässt sich komplett übers Webinterface steuern.
Das ist Wohnzimmer Leak.
Aber keinerlei Connection mehr zur China Chinesen Cloud.
Das ist rein offline wie ich meinen Staubsauger verwenden kann.
So muss das sein. So also jetzt aber endlich schon mal Einkaufsliste.
Tja wie gesagt weiß ich ob ich mir das ganze kaufen soll.
Chat hat einer von euch so ein Ding?
Das ist ein Lötkolben. Das ist ein besonders kompakter Lötkolben.
Den man beispielsweise über USB betreiben kann.
Entweder direkt mit einem Quick Charge Adapter oder über einem Powerbank.
Hast du eigentlich einen Discord? Ja hab ich.
Ich hab einen. Also ich brauch keinen.
Aber ich find die Idee hier hinter ganz gut dass du damit beispielsweise auch wenn ich mal was im Stall machen muss
oder hinten im Garten machen muss in irgendwie irgendwo mal ein Kabel was halt wo ich halt keinen Bock hab auf meine Lötstation
dann würde ich ne Powerbank nehmen.
Ist das nicht USB?
Doch doch klar ist das USB.
Der TS80 ist mit einem Klinkgestecker.
Warte mal Moment.
Die Dinger haben doch USB.
Der TS80 Power mit dringend Quick Charge.
Moment.
Siehst du da sind wir schon dabei.
Ich dachte das geht über USB.
Ja und wie betreibt man den dann?
Weil ich meine ich muss den ja eine Powerbank kriegen.
Ah Firefox kaputt ok excellent.
Und wie ist das jetzt?
Ich dachte da ist mit USB weil ich also ich fand die Idee halt gut
dass ich einfach eine Powerbank nehmen kann und dann USB und ab geht die Post ja.
Und wie funktioniert jetzt hier die Stromversorgung?
Hat das ein Akku drin? Nee das ergibt doch keinen Sinn.
Ach hier.
Ach man braucht nen 12 Volt Ding. Wie schließt man gibt es?
Wie schließt man den denn dann an eine Powerbank an?
Weil wenn ich da Netzteil für brauche dann ist es also ein richtiges Netzteil
für den Stecker dann ist doch sinnlos oder?
Powerbank.
Na ja gut wie auch immer.
Ich habe mich interessiert ob den einer von euch hat
weil ich fand die Idee von einem mobilen Nerdkolben echt ganz nice.
Aber mit USB ist natürlich dann schon praktischer
also wenn du eine Powerbank anschließen kannst.
Powerbank hat auch nicht genug Power für den Lötkolben.
Doch hat es. Du brauchst eine Powerbank mit Quick Charge.
Brauchst eine Powerbank mit Quick Charge.
Also normal geht auch.
Ich habe ja so einen ganz ganz billigen USB Lötkolben
so einen ganz ganz billigen. Den habe ich mir eigentlich nur gekauft
Just for Fun. So so ein Teil hier.
Das Teil habe ich mir mal gekauft.
Das ist so dermaßen scheiße.
Ich habe es mir eigentlich nur gekauft weil ich wissen wollte ob es funktioniert.
Das ist Leute wenn ihr den schlechtesten Lötkolben
aller Zeiten haben wollt dann kauft den hier.
Ich meine er funktioniert er funktioniert
übrigens auch bei ganz normalen USB Stecker.
Ja also es funktioniert es wird auch heiß genug
aber es ist wirklich richtig scheiße Strom über Klinke.
Ja also letztendlich über USB.
Aber hier dann darin haben sie über Klinker Anschluss gemacht.
Aber es ist es ist fail. Also das Ding ist wirklich mega mega kacke.
Also es funktioniert aber ich habe damit schon mal was gelötet.
Schon sogar ein paar Sachen wo ich was ganz kleines kompaktes mal gebraucht habe.
Aber schön ist es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Graslötkolben
Tja ok da werde ich das erstmal verwerfen die Idee wieder so etwas zu kaufen.
Ich dachte mir es ist vielleicht ganz nice so mobile Lötkolben am Start zu haben
weil es mit der Powerbank geht.
Aber die Powerbank ist danach je nachdem wie lange sie danach logischerweise leer.
Aber für ein bisschen sollte das schon reichen.
Ok manche sagen wir brauchen Adapter ist aber nice.
Saugroboter mit 400 ja aber das dumme ist dass die meisten davon nichts taugen.
Du brauchst ja einen guten Staubsauger Roboter plus eine Absaugestation.
TS-80P
Ah ok.
Und der geht über über USB oder USB wie die coolen Leute sagen.
Ok muss man mal gucken.
Ich kaufe mir da jetzt nichts.
Ich kaufe ich kaufe ich mir nichts.
Kaufe ich keine keine gute Idee.
Aber wo wir gerade beim Thema löten sind was ich mir kaufen wollte.
Ich habe letztens sowas hier gefunden.
Na was muss ich denn da suchen wie hieß das hier sowas.
Sowas habe ich letztens gesehen und ich glaube das wäre was echt praktisches.
Ich habe mir ja mal vor einer Weile so ein billiges so billiges Set gekauft
mit so Sachen die du an Tisch klemmen kannst.
Also diese diese Krokodilklemmen die man an Tisch machen kann die sind aber richtig
Scheiße die ich mir da gekauft habe.
Die verwende ich nicht.
Und jetzt habe ich überlegt ob ich mal sowas hier auch holen soll.
Und das macht einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Also das macht einen recht stabilen Eindruck von dem.
Wo steht es hier.
Mit 1,5 Kilo.
Ich meine das Ding ist nicht groß.
Das ist irgendwie 30 30 also 25 mal 25.
Wenn man sich irgendwie quadratisch vorstellen will und wiegt 1,5 Kilo.
Also das ist schon nicht super schwer.
Aber es reicht auf jeden Fall.
So also ich weiß nicht ob ihr sowas am Start habt.
Aber ich glaube das wird das der wird es werden.
Den habe ich letztens gesehen habe mir noch ein paar Sachen angeguckt zu.
Das hat einen guten Eindruck gemacht.
Ich meine es hat es hat kein Absaugung oder sonst was.
Aber wozu.
Was Fenster oft danach.
Ja also das das das wird es wahrscheinlich werden.
So was ich da noch brauche ist.
Weil ich mir da auch nicht ganz sicher bin ob es da was Gescheites gibt.
Ich habe mittlerweile so viele micro SD Karten rum.
Gibt es da irgendwie so einen Sammler oder irgendwie so ein Behälter der was taugt.
Wobei das kann ich mir doch bestimmt 3D drucken.
Moment das kann ich mein 3D Drucker mal für was sinnvolles verwenden.
Ich muss ja nicht schön aussehen.
Ok so was gibt es ist viel zu wenig.
Ich brauche was für 20 micro SD Karten.
Also im Prinzip sowas hier.
Ok ok das Moment dass das da gucken wir jetzt mal was man 3D drucken könnte.
micro SD micro SD Mappe soll ich suchen.
Ja ist ja sowas hier.
Also mir reicht es wenn es nur micro SD ist.
Ich brauche ehrlich gesagt gar nichts anderes.
Das ist ja Big Brain.
Oh das ist cool das gefällt mir.
Das kann man jetzt.
Ich weiß nicht ob man die aktuell noch flashen kann.
Die aktuellen HD 10s.
Das finde ich ist eine coole Idee hier.
Vor allem es ist halt nur für micro SD Karten.
Und es passt ziemlich kompakt was rein.
Wisst ihr was ich dann immer nicht verstehe.
Die Leute machen so ein cooles Model.
Und dann drucken sie es in der schlechtmöglichen Qualität aus.
Oder machen ein scheiß Foto von.
Also wenn ich da ein Model rein stellen würde.
Würde ich zumindest die Oberfläche noch ein bisschen nach bearbeiten.
Dass es nicht so Monarch S mäßig aussieht.
Aber die Idee finde ich doch sehr nice.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Das ist auch cool.
Aber da sind auch wieder so viele Sachen drin die ich nicht brauche.
Hier kann ich mir doch ausdrucken was ich will.
Das sind micro SD Karten.
Da könnte ich mir im Prinzip einfach.
Sechs solcher micro SD Karten Behälter ausdrücken.
Brauchst halt genau passende Schraube für.
Also ich glaube Schrauben habe ich wirklich mehr als genug hier.
Ok das ist eine coole Sache.
Ich glaube ich drücke mir sowas aus.
Warum sollte ich sowas kaufen?
Da kann ich mein 3D-Druck.
Da kann ich mir ein bisschen Filament wieder verschwenden.
Die raus zu bekommen sieht schwierig aus.
Da hast du Recht.
Moment.
Wo war denn das?
Das konnte man da von unten dagegen drücken wenn man das rausgedingst hat.
Ok wenn du einen sehr kleinen Finger hast kannst du da unten dagegen drücken.
Aber mit meinem Pippega Pippega Pippo Fettfinger komme ich da wahrscheinlich nicht dazwischen.
Ich glaube es ist relativ dick.
Ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht.
Sowas ist aber eigentlich auch ganz cool.
Aber ich brauche halt nicht die normalen SD Karten.
Ich habe außer für lasst mal überlegen wo habe ich noch normale SD Karten.
Für den für die Kamera und für den Audio Recorder.
Beides verwende ich eigentlich nicht regelmäßig.
Stimmt eigentlich könnte ich das stimmt eigentlich könnte ich dieses Teil hier ausdrucken.
So ein so ein Ding ausdrucken einfach und gucken ob es passt.
Und wenn es passt drücke ich den Rest aus.
Das ist ja gerade das gute am 3D Drucker.
CS Mountain Juni aber ich habe auf GitHub wenn auch nicht top aktuell habe ich Files von mir.
Wenn der Browser mag.
Hat dieses Projekt nicht ein schönes Logo.
Also ich finde das ist immer noch das beste GitHub Logo von allen GitHub Projekten.
Das ist so billig dass es schon wieder gut ist.
So irgendwo habe ich hier meine meine Dot Files da.
Und da hast du auch den ganzen Kram da hast du unter anderem auch die.
E3 Konfig aber die E3 Konfig an sich reicht dir ja nicht.
Also wenn du das haben willst du brauchst die passende Status Bar.
Aber es ist alles drin ist alles ist alles drin.
Also wenn du das clones hast das sieht es mehr oder weniger so aus wie bei mir.
Bis auf ein paar Kleinigkeiten vielleicht.
Ah sorry Shithub ja natürlich.
So also das speichere ich mir mal ich glaube ich drücke da mal ein aus später.
Moment was habe ich denn da noch in meinem Korb.
Erstmal muss ich mal kurz den Darkruider ausmachen sieht kacke aus.
Oh Flashbang.
Oh meine Augen ich sehe nichts.
Blinded.
Ok das Case kann ich wobei gibt es die gerade das Case kann man nicht genug haben.
Ja easy lasse ich.
Oh na doch ist ja liefer.
Die Leute das Case lasse ich nochmal drinne schadet auf jeden Fall nichts.
So nächstes also was braucht man als nächstes.
Ich muss mal kurz abhaken.
Also dritte Hand haben wir TS 100 lohnt sich nicht.
Dann habe ich hier irgendwie noch ein Ali Express Eintrag was auch immer das ist.
Mal kurz gucken.
Ok.
Ja.
Ich habe aus irgendwelchen Gründen mir was gebookmarkt von Ali Express aber der Link geht nicht mehr.
Ah doch ach ja da wollte ich mir noch aber ich weiß nicht ob ich mir das bei Ali Express bestelle.
Ich habe mir diese Thermostate gekauft zum Selbstflaschen ich wollte mir jetzt endlich nochmal einen
Viererpack kaufen weil ich mein Viererpack für 13 Euro kannst du dich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Die Dinger sind wirklich nice.
Ich habe mir wie gesagt ich habe mir ein Ziel gekauft habe ich geflasht mit einer Custom
Firmware von.
Von GitHub.
Genau hier Custom Firmware haben wir geflasht.
Die da haben wir übrigens auch im Stream gemacht hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Und jetzt verbraucht das Ding deutlich weniger Batterie als mit der offiziellen Firmware.
Die offizielle Firmware hält irgendwie nur zwei Monate oder so.
Und mit der Firmware kann ich das wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein Jahr oder so laufen lassen.
OTA-Flash.
Man muss nichts löten.
Über Bluetooth kann man flaschen.
Und es hat ein paar Zusatzfunktionen.
Also erstens kann man den Kram ordentlich kalibrieren was man mit der original Firmware
auch nicht kann.
Man kann Batteriestand und Uhr noch anzeigen lassen auf dem Ding.
Flaschen über Bluetooth.
Hast du das nicht geprikt?
Ne das geht wieder.
Ich dachte erst dass ich es geprikt habe weil ich mich nicht connecten konnte.
Aber ich habe mich dann ich habe dann 50 mal connect gespammt und dann ging es wieder.
Offstream.
So und jetzt habe ich mir halt überlegt.
Kaufen wir halt einfach noch mal einen Vierer-Pack.
Ich meine für 13, 13 Euro kannst du da nicht all zu viel verkehrt machen.
Für was kriege ich denn das gerade auf?
Bei Amazon.
Alter bei Amazon.
Haben die überhaupt einen Mehrfach-Pack?
10,80 Euro.
Hier kriege ich eins für den Preis bei AliExpress.
Wie ich da vier für kriege.
Gibt es da irgendwie Dreier-Pack oder so?
Das ist wieder was anderes.
Lustigerweise wenn ich auf Google auf der.
What the fuck?
Warum findet man das bei Amazon nicht?
Könnt ihr mir das mal erklären warum habe ich das jetzt bei Amazon nicht gefunden?
Und hier finde ich es jetzt wenn ich über Google such.
Ein Dreier-Pack.
Wo ist da wo ist da der Sinn?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Print Kai Shei Guan.
Alles klar.
Aber es kostet auch guck mal.
Hier kosten 3,22 Euro und bei AliExpress kosten einfach 4,13 Euro.
Ich bestell mir das bei den chinesischen China Shops.
So.
Bam.
Vier Stück.
Shipping.
AliExpress Standard.
Bam.
Voraus.
Okay also eins muss man ja sagen.
Die Chinesen haben es mit Rechnen nicht so.
Weil 10 Tage Versand ist halt nicht bis zum 10.
Mai.
So also in den Einkaufskorb.
Bam.
Jaja fortfahren.
Gut.
Next.
Was habe ich als nächstes?
Das muss ich mal abhaken.
Moment abhaken.
Abhaken.
Ja kennt einer von euch gutes doppelseitiges Klebeband.
Ich habe.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen ausprobiert und.
Irgendeiner meinte dann das letzte Mal ich glaube von der Arbeit noch irgendwie ultra Geheimtipp wird auch für Autos verwendet oder sonst was irgendwie 3M.
So irgendwie sowas hier.
Habe ich habe ich mir gekauft.
Das das Ding.
So aber das ist kacke.
Das ist mega Sack.
Ich habe das.
Ich habe das im Keller an den an die an den Verteiler Schrank gemacht und habe.
Dort einem 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse dran geklebt.
Mit einem ESP drin und es ist drei Tage später abgefallen.
Also das stelle ich mir nicht unter extra stark vor.
Wenn du das bisschen erwärmst muss man das warm machen.
Muss man das warm machen.
Wo steht das das man das warm machen muss.
Also wie gesagt das hat mich jetzt nicht so nicht so begeistert.
Es fühlt sich extrem bappig an.
Aber es klebt.
Habe ich geklebt.
Was nach was soll ich suchen V was V H B.
Moment ist das das ist doch das gleiche hier oder ist das jetzt was anderes.
Sieht genauso aus wie das aber ich habe jetzt was anderes.
Okay man muss draufdrücken.
Das ist doch genau das gleiche das hatte ich noch eben schon.
Also wie gesagt das vielleicht habe ich es auch falsch.
Also ich meine ich habe es an den ich habe es an den Schrank gemacht ich habe das 3D gedruckte Gehäuse genommen.
Da irgendwie eine halbe Minute dran gedrückt und dann habe ich es hängen lassen und drei Tage später ist abgefallen.
ultra krab gewesen.
Es sollte eigentlich nicht sein.
Teaser extra strong Teaser ist gar nicht das das noch gibt Teaser extra strong Universal Flex wird geflext.
Ich weiß nicht ob das was taugt Leute das ist die Sache ich bräuchte halt mal was.
Aber irgendwie nichts gefunden einfach dübeln ja dübeln mal was in den Verteilerschrank von der Seite dran.
Exzellent Idee.
Heißkleber du wirst lachen das habe ich mir das habe ich mir überlegt.
Ich habe da unten im Keller gestanden ich habe da unten im Keller gestanden wo ich gesehen habe das es abgefallen ist und ich war kurz davor Heißkleber zu holen.
Weil der Scheiß hält.
Ich meine ich habe mit dem Heißkleber auf einer Fensterbank ein Raspberry Pi festgeklebt und da klebt der jetzt schon seit über einem Jahr und das juckt das überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe mir eine Kamera gebaut hinten für den Hof mit einem Raspberry Pi Zero.
Den Raspberry Pi Zero habe ich in einen großen Schrumpfschlauch gesteckt und habe es wasserdicht gemacht damit und dann habe ich einfach mit einem riesen Klumpen Heißkleber an die Fensterbank gepappt.
Das ist halt über einem Jahr Wind Wetter Sturm Regen juckt es nicht es hält einfach Bomben fest auf der Fensterbank.
Also Heißkleber ist immer noch beste Leute.
Wird er nicht zu warm das Bedenken die Bedenken hatte ich auch am Anfang es ist ja auch noch ein schwarzer Schrumpfschlauch in dem da drin ist.
Ich hatte auch das Bedenken das wenn da die Sonne drauf scheint ein paar Stunden am Tag das er zu warm wird aber nö funktioniert.
Funktioniert.
Gibt es keine Probleme mit.
Also wirklich also Heißkleber ist echt eines der besten Erfindungen.
Ich Heißkleber mittlerweile auch unsinnig viel einfach weil es funktioniert ich meine nicht so viel wie die Chinesen die ihre Sachen quasi mit Heißkleber auffüllen.
Aber wenn ich irgendwo was dran machen will sei es jetzt Elektro Zeug wo ich am besten also was in ein Gehäuse kommt einfach erstmal Heißkleber rein gesprayt dran gepappt hält.
Easy.
Huge Heißkleber.
Dann hake ich das mal ab mir fällt hier auch nichts gescheites ein.
Übrigens hat jemand von euch so ein Ding.
Hat jemand von euch so ein Teil.
Zeigt mal hier was ist Link.
Kleben statt bohren bis zu 120 Kilo.
Das klingt gut.
Kleben statt bohren.
120 Kilo das ist aber auch nur.
Je nachdem wenn du eine ganz große Fläche machst oder.
Der Schrank ist aus Metall Magnet ans Gehäuse.
Das würde wahrscheinlich sogar funktionieren.
Aber 120 Kilo hält das Ding doch nur aus wenn du quasi irgendwie einen Meter lang vollklebst oder so.
120 Kilo ist halt die Frage auf welcher Fläche 120 Kilo 120 Kilo über 2 Quadratmeter ist jetzt.
Pro Rolle.
Okay.
Komm scheiß drauf aber hat hat jemand von euch so ein Teil.
Amazon sagt mir nichts über den Preis der Preis ist unsinnig will ich nicht bezahlen ehrlich gesagt.
Hat jemand so ein Ding ich finde es von der Idee her ganz cool.
Das ist eine Uhr die kannst du mit beispielsweise mit Home Assistant oder anderen Sachen kannst du custom Sachen drauf anzeigen lassen.
Also kannst du zum Beispiel Home Assistant Notifications drauf machen oder was auch immer.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen so richtigen Anwendungszweck für aber ich finde ich weiß dass man theoretisch sowas selbst bauen kann.
Aber ich finde die Idee ganz cool.
Zumal die Verarbeitung auch ganz gut aussieht also besser wie selbst gedrucktes Gehäuse und sowas aber der Preis ist halt lächerlich.
Der Preis ist halt absolut lächerlich.
Ich gebe doch keine 200 Euro für sowas aus ich meine da ist wahrscheinlich auch nur ein ESP 2866 drin oder sowas.
Irgend so billiges Chinesen Zeug.
Und dann halt kein 3D gedrucktes Gehäuse sondern irgendwas anderes.
Aber wofür brauchst du das ich brauch das gar nicht.
Genau die ich finde die Idee cool aber der Preis ist zu teuer.
Ich brauch das gar nicht wenn ich mir nur Sachen kaufen würde die ich wirklich brauche.
Dann würde ich hier bei Wasser und Brot sitzen und sonst nichts machen.
Ja der Scheiß ist viel zu teuer.
Sackt alter ich finde die Idee von solchen Pixel Dingern richtig cool ehrlich gesagt.
Aber eigentlich alles viel zu teuer.
Das ist auch nice das halte ich doch hier gerade auf oder ist das was anderes was der Chat gerade picks Backpack.
Ach ja habe ich euch auf Twitter eigentlich schon gezeigt was mir gestern oder vorgestern jemand gepostet hat.
Weil ich hier gerade einen Rucksack sehe da hat jemand in der Bahn gepostet mit einem Rucksack wo Rare Parrot draufläuft.
Das könnte sogar sowas hier in der Richtung gewesen sein.
Guck mal.
Das ist nicht nice.
Das ist doch so ein Teil oder.
Das ist doch so ein Ding.
Sowas brauche ich.
Ist er ist er das zufälligerweise sogar.
Ist ist er das zufälligerweise sogar.
Dieser Rucksack ist das das.
Drei Familie hat funktioniert.
Das ist das oder.
Das ist was anderes.
Aber das ist da nicht guck mal das Händel.
Das Händel sieht komplett anders aus.
Das sieht anders aus.
Was kostet sowas denn?
Was kostet so ein Spaß?
160 Euro guck mal bei dem anderen kostet die Uhr bei dem anderen kostet die Uhr schon so viel.
Pixel Backpack gibt es das gibt es das gibt es das in Deutschland zu kaufen.
Frag mich ob das wasserdicht ist.
Ja guck mal für 100 Euro easy.
Das ist nice.
Gibt es dafür gescheite Firmware oder geht es nur mit der offiziellen App kann man das sag mal kann man das animieren.
Oder kann man da nur Bilder drauf anzeigen.
Animation Animated Pixel Art Backpack.
Das ist cool das brauche ich.
Aber aber.
Also eine Diskette eine Diskette als als Powerbank oder was ist das ist mir zu hipster.
Das ist so möchte gern Retro Hipster Style.
Aber die Idee mit dem mit dem Plinker fürs Fahrrad ist schon cool oder.
AliExpress ne ich kaufe mir jetzt nichts bei AliExpress oder ist bei AliExpress der.
Das könnte der sein bei AliExpress den der eine hatte doch tatsächlich.
Guck mal.
Das sieht eher nach dem aus was der was der Typ hatte im Video.
Ja ja guck mal.
Das ist der das ist der Rucksack.
Guck mal das sieht das sieht das sieht original so aus.
Guck mal das ist der AliExpress Käufer hier seht ihr.
China chinesische chinesische chinesen Bestellung am Start.
Metawall die China Namen sind immer so geil Metawall Mall Metawall.
Die Chinesischen angeblichen Markennamen das wirkt immer als hat einer random.
Aus dem englischen Wörterbuch einfach zwei Wörter genommen und zusammen kopiert.
Aber den hier finde ich echt ich bin aber überlegen ob ich mir so ein Ding kaufen.
Kaufen soll so einfach die Sache ist halt es ist halt und es ist halt brutal unsinnig.
Aber es ist irgendwie auch da ist da konnte ich meinen Keks als pixel art.
Hinten drauf machen überlegt euch das doch mal.
Da kann ich da kann ich einfach aber dann erkennt man mich ja.
Ich würde Gatschi Bass Hyper Gatschi mache ich hinten drauf Leute Hyper Gatschi.
Ich komme da hinten auf den Rucksack.
Bisschen grinschig ist das schon.
Ja ist es Gämsch dir recht.
Kommt aber ein bisschen aufs Motiv an.
Gibt es dafür ok.
Github gibt es dafür ordentliche Firmware.
Erst mal flaschen.
Anscheinend nicht.
Wie heißt das Ding PIX PIX.
PIX PIX POO.
Es ist ja so.
Ne PIX PIX POO.
Ok.
Also damit kann man C.L.I.
script controlling pixel devices.
Alter ist das ist das die Musik klingt wie der Typ.
Ach das ist ok.
Klingt ein bisschen wie dieser Dude kennt noch einer den Flöter von der Ubisoft Präsentation.
Das war der beste.
Ubisoft Flutgeil.
Moment war das überhaupt Ubisoft.
Moment.
Ach ne das war gar nicht Ubisoft.
Der Flutgeil.
Ghost of Tsushima ist wer.
Sony war das Sony direkt Sony.
Oder von wem waren das nochmal.
Sucker Punch.
Die haben das auf der auf der Playstation Presse Konferenz wahrscheinlich raus.
Der Flöter hier war der beste.
Beste E3 Präsentation überhaupt.
Ah yes.
Vor allem wenn du das dann 2 Stunden 15 anhören willst.
Zwar ist da aber nicht 2 Stunden 15.
2 Minuten 15 die anhören musst und dann hast du gedacht Alter wann gehts denn endlich los.
Der ist doch voll dabei.
Der fehlt das richtig diese Flöte ja.
Oh oh jetzt will er es wissen.
Jetzt gibt er alles.
Gleich gibt es die nächste Lootbox Unlocked.
Die Flöte ist schepp.
Guck mal die ist kaputt.
Der hat schon so wild geflöte, dass das Ding schon gebogen ist.
Nordas Leute.
Wo sind die Nordas im Chat.
Jetzt geht er ab.
Huge.
Ich dachte er ist fertig.
Aber wenigstens war es was anderes.
Ich habe das Spiel weder gekauft noch mir angeguckt.
Ich glaube aber das ist ganz gut geworden ehrlich gesagt.
Okay jetzt ist die große Preisfrage.
Kaufe ich mir so einen Kack Rucksack oder nicht.
Ich finde wie lange hält denn die Batterie davon.
Wie lange hält denn die Batterie von so einem Teil.
Pixel.
Moment Pixel ich muss Backpack suchen.
Akku.
Kurztest.
Akku Laufzeit.
5 Minuten.
Wait a minute.
Kack Kack Kack Wait.
Ja ja ich bin mit allem einverstanden.
Ich brauche Akku Laufzeit.
Oder muss man eine Powerbank oder muss man.
Was 24 Stunden ernsthaft.
Oder muss man einfach eine Powerbank rein machen noch zusätzlich.
Okay man muss eine Powerbank Träger anschließen.
Okay.
So ich ruf auf eine Powerbank.
Mindestens 2x4 und eine Powerbank von denen.
Soll ich es nicht im Lieferumfang halten.
Das macht nichts.
Und wie viel Stromverbrauch.
Ja 24 Stunden das hält das hängt ganz entscheidend von der von der Powerbank ab.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es 24 Stunden an der Powerbank hält.
Okay wie lange hält das mit einer Powerbank.
Ich meine das sollte schon so einen Arbeitstag halten.
Einfach Windkraftanlage auf den Kopf setzen.
Das haltet ihr von der Idee.
Ich laufe einfach zusätzlich noch mit so einer Mühle rum.
Und lasst es am Kopf kreiseln.
Das steht 24 Stunden mit 5000 milliampere.
Das ist was anderes.
Wieder nichts von 24 Stunden.
Genau so ein Hut ziehe ich dann auf.
Aber gehen wir mal von aus das hält zumindest mal den Hin und Rückweg durch.
Ich finde die Idee mega nice.
Aber auf der anderen Seite bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher.
Gehen wir in den Akku mal hier in die Beschreibung gucken.
Fantastiko.
Natürlich ist das Geldverschwendung.
Obwohl ich mir halt nicht sicher bin ob ich den dann auch wirklich anziehe wenn ich ihn habe.
Weil ein bisschen cringe ist es ja schon.
Ach der ist for girls.
Dann darf ich den ja gar nicht anziehen.
Aus dem warum assume die dass ich kein Girl bin was soll das.
Abmahnung ist raus.
Nee ich kaufe das nicht.
Das ist zu schwachsinnig.
Das ist das komplette Geldverschwendung.
Ich kaufe mir an sich nicht viel.
Aber manchmal lasse ich mich auch.
Lasse sogar ich mich dazu sinnloser Geldverschwendung.
Hin reißen.
Wenn ich jetzt Fahrrad fahren würde und man damit wenigstens blinken könnte so was wie
einer geschrieben hat das wäre ja noch cool.
Aber ich fahre kein Fahrrad zumindest nicht in Frankfurt.
Nee.
Nee nee nee.
Also hake ich jetzt auch mal ab.
Das ist Schwachsinn das kaufe ich nicht.
Übrigens ich weiß es weicht jetzt etwas vom Einkaufen ab ich wollte euch noch was anderes zeigen.
Hier mal auf Fiverr.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen umgeguckt auf Fiverr.
Und Moment Flashbang.
Ich lasse mir einen 3D Keks machen.
Ich lasse mir hier einen 3D Keks machen und dann mache ich dann hier 3D Keks VTuber.
Das blöde ist ich kann mir unglaublich schlecht vorstellen wie die ganzen Anime
Grill Leute hier gutes Keks 3D Modeln machen wollen.
Ich finde die Idee aber lustig.
Manch einer wird jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen.
Ich finde die Idee lustig.
Leider leider kann man sich anhand dieser Models.
Außer dass der Pedobear hier gleich um die Ecke gelaufen.
WTF kann man sich hier schlecht einschätzen wer da was hinbekommt.
Also 2D ist nicht das Problem.
2D gibt es richtig gute Leute wenn man hier nach 2D Sachen sucht.
Auch wenn das alles wieder äußerst pedobearig ist.
Wie sagt das Ebaro immer die sind ja eigentlich 3000 Jahre alt.
Ich kenne mich da nicht so aus.
Aber so einen Keks sollten sie noch hinbekommen.
Und dann gibt es demnächst Keks VTubing.
Das wäre mega lustig.
Wo ist der Ebaro wenn man ihn braucht.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Hat mal einer was vom Ebaro gehört in letzter Zeit.
Wo ist der Cute Mod.
Vielleicht hat es ja geklappt mit seinem Lehramts Grill.
Dann ist der Cute Mod jetzt erstmal weg.
Dann sehen wir den in einem halben Jahr erst wieder.
Der Cute Mod war kurz im Discord.
Na da bin ich ja beruhigt.
Dann ist alles in Ordnung.
Gut nein so ein Schwachsinn glaube ich mir nicht.
Bäm weg.
Dann brauche ich noch.
Das ist jetzt aber sehr unspektakulär.
Ich bin am gucken ob es Silikonkabel.
Auch genau so was.
Easy sind es Silikonkabel.
Genau so was brauche ich.
Gut hat es schon erledigt.
Das sind Silikonkabel oder sind das Silikonkabel.
Nee das sind keine Silikonkabel.
Ich hätte gerne sowas als Silikonkabel.
Weil die so schön biegsam sind.
Also noch biegsamer als die normalen.
Sowas als Silikonkabel das wäre Pock.
Warum findet Amazon das eigentlich unter Silikon.
Wie viel ist denn da drauf.
40 Fuß was sind denn 40 Fuß in Meter.
12 Meter ok.
Das Fleisch ist ja nicht flexibel.
Ok guck mal mal.
Flexibel.
Das ist alles nicht so das.
Die sind aber auch nicht flexibel.
Also die Silikonkabel sind halt insofern ganz cool.
Weil die super biegsam sind.
Und ich hätte halt gerne so ein 4Pin schon komplett zusammen.
Weil sowas hier kannst du halt auch easy als Sensorkabel verwenden.
Sensor dran.
Und wenn du super ordentlich bist machst du irgendwie so ein Geflechtsschlauch drum oder so.
Aber braucht man den eigentlich nicht.
Rechnen Quickmuffs.
Und ich habe heute ein Video gesehen auf YouTube.
Der hatte mega Big Brain Idee.
Und zwar der hat AJ11 Kabel genommen.
Für seine Sensoren.
Silikonkabel ja aber ich hätte gerne eins mit 4 drinne.
Woodbite mit 4 Kabeln.
Der hat für seine Sensoren AJ11 Kabel genommen.
Und dann hatte der so einen Breakout Board.
Das fand ich richtig Big Brain sowas hier in der Richtung.
Nur nicht so teuer.
Das fand ich äußerst nice die Idee.
Der hat dann seine Sensoren an AJ45 Stecker gemacht.
Und hatte dann so einen Breakout Board an seinem Controller.
Das heißt du hast keinen rumgefundelt mehr mit irgendwelchen Pins.
Du kannst außen an deinem Gehäuse einfach einen Stecker mit Clips machen.
Und innen greifst du es ab.
Wahrscheinlich tut es ja jeder AJ45 Stecker oder?
Sowas hier im Endeffekt.
Na das machst du ins Gehäuse rein.
Und hinten greifst du ganz normal.
Plus Minus und theoretisch zweimal Data ab.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache.
Geht natürlich nur wenn du die andere Seite auch selbst designst.
Uns funktioniert es natürlich nicht.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall besser als irgendwelche fest verlöteten Kabel.
Die du dann im Zweifelsfall wieder ablöten musst im Keller.
Weil irgendwas nicht passt.
Aber glaube ich nicht, dass ich mir sowas kaufe jetzt erstmal.
Aber ich fand die Idee nur ziemlich gut.
Guck mal der Chat.
Der Chat findet hier wieder die ganzen Sachen.
Chat kennt sich aus.
Das macht aber einen ziemlich starren Eindruck für Silikon oder?
Aber genau sowas suche ich.
Allerdings.
Wahre mir beschrieben.
Die Wartezeit entspricht meiner Wartung ja schön.
Die sind ganz schön dünn.
Ich ganz ehrlich, ich weiß auch nicht, warum die den Kram nicht einfach mal scharf fotografieren konnten.
Aber für Sensoren reichen die auf jeden Fall aus.
Die Sensoren sind 3,3 Volt, 5 Volt und paar Milliampere.
Dafür reicht der im Endeffekt.
Gibt es ja eigentlich fast nichts, was dafür nicht reicht.
Kannst wahrscheinlich mit einem Haar verbinden oder so.
Aber sowas, aber ich mag Silikonkabel, weil die halt so super elastisch sind.
Hier gibt es noch mehr.
Aber Leute, die Dinger sind doch im Leben nicht.
Das sind doch stinknormale Kabel.
Das sind stinknormale Kabel, wo einer eine Silikonhülle drum gemacht hat oder?
Die sind auch nicht flexibler als alles andere.
Sieht zumindest nicht so aus.
Aber das Kabel ist sehr flexibel.
Das Kabel ist sehr flexibel, genau sowas suche ich.
Teuer, aber es gibt keine Alternative.
Erstmal 50 Meter für 30 Billionen Euro.
Sie sind kacke zum Abisolieren.
Kann man das einfach abschneiden?
Wenn es gar nicht geht, nimmst du ein Teppichmesser.
Hätte ich jetzt gedacht.
Neben das gibt es keine Probleme.
Das ist so klein, da erkenne ich überhaupt nicht, was das sein soll.
Bitte größere Fotos machen.
Ich brauche das, um Sensoren zu verbinden.
Ich will da nicht neue Hausverkabelung machen.
Ich brauche auch nichts für außen.
Das ist alles overkill.
Das ist alles flexibel, wo ich Sensoren mit 3,3 oder 5 Volt verbinden kann.
Die gehen etwas zu leicht.
Das ist eher ein Kabel für einen ESP-Sensor.
Erstmal das fetteste Kabel überhaupt rausholen.
Ich brauche ein agiles Kabel.
Ich bin die letzten Streams schon am überlegen.
Silikonkabel sind flexibler.
Jumperkabel sind kurz.
Meistens hängen sie nicht zusammen und sind einzeln.
Man kann lange in eine Rolle Jumperkabel nehmen, die zusammenhängen.
Am besten mit Silikon.
Davon 4 Stück zusammen.
Wenn du den Sensor drankleben willst und dann 50-100 cm mehr zum ESP legen.
Zum Beispiel den Sensor zum Stromzähler zählen, an den Stromzähler pappen
und der ESP liegt unten im Schrank.
Kein Ding.
Der Chat ist schon wieder am Posten.
ripped
noch in unterschiedlichen farben ja das ist ziemlich stunden aber für die
sensoren reicht das es reicht über solche kabel über solche mini kabel
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern so die richtig ganz kleinen furz kabel über
diese ganz normalen kleinen jumper kabel habe ich weihnachtsbeleuchtung gemacht
fünf volt ich glaube acht ampere war nicht zehn weil mehr das netzteil nicht
konnte fünf voll acht ampere über das kabel ich habe mir ein bisschen finger
verbrannt und die kabel waren äußerst flexibel muss ich sagen bei der
temperatur die waren äußerst flexibel die werden halt kurz die waren halt kurz
vom schmelzen
nimm einfach ein altes usb kabel genauso mache ich das aktuell ich habe nur ein
altes usb kabel genommen habt auf beiden seiten abgemacht den sensor dran
gemacht welche die lungs die so was ist man starrer mit die drei wm haben wir
noch moment haben wir noch den stream wo ich mit den finger verbrannt habe
seck den finde ich den finde ich schnell oder gar nicht
led pimp mal weihnachtsbaum das müsste sein rgb led leiste
ich glaube hier habe ich mir ich glaube hier habe ich mit finger verbrannt 24
der elfte also merkt euch mal hier 24 der elfte oder siebte zwölfte
obs faltest ja 24 11 ja ja ich glaube hier habe ich mit finger verbrannt nur
für sensoren ist das hier zu empfehlen ja das ist cool genau so was sucht
das was hat das was hat das jetzt gemacht was habe ich denn jetzt hier
getippt von ks
so ja so was ist ganz gut aber wie viel kabel sind denn da
drinnen zwanzig stück oder wie
aber sonderlich flexibel ist das nett oder das sind vier das sind vier
botte ich sehe da mindestens acht verschiedene und wie flexibel ist das oder
woher weiß man dass das jetzt flexibel ist
hoher anzahl anwesend trocken feucht gelegentlich bewegt was li yy ist hoch
flexibel ok das speicher ich mir mal auf 50 50 meter gibt es vielleicht auch
kürzer das bild ist richtig gebatet der moment also mal schnell gucken wo habe
ich den finger verbrannt also erst mal also erst mal höhere auflösung ja ich
war nämlich so blöd in dem stream und hab hier vorne hier über diese über
diese jumpa kabel habe ich klick mal auf mein link zeige ich mal her die jumpa
über so diese jumpa kabels habe ich dann gedacht mache ich 5 volt 8 ampere das
war zu viel hätte das gedacht ja so was genau so was in der
richtung vier polisch fünf meter ja ist ja richtig günstig besser besser als bei
amazon ok 1 9 90 ich probiere das mal aus ich probiere das mal aus ob das
wirklich so flexibel ist wie ich es gerne hätte
also pass mal auf gucken ob ich das ich muss mal schnell gucken ob ich das
finde also was kann das netzteil ich glaube es war ein 5 5 voll 8 ampere das
netzteil
so
die scha die scheiß chinesen spannungswandler haben wir drei nicht
zwei zwei dieser boards gegrillt
so ein moment wo wo verbrennt er sich die finger
habe habe ich mir schon die finger verbrannt weil ich weil ich gerade
gucken ob es warm wird ach moment moment ich kann aktuell hängt ja
noch gar nichts dran warum sollte das warm werden
wo verbrenne ich mir die finger ich finde es net hier hier genau jetzt
schließe ich es an und dann verbrenne ich mir die finger google docs please okay
genau da kann ich mich dran guck mal über diese kleine jumper kabel über
diese kleinen mini jumper kabels mache ich das ist ich glaube sind 5 8
ampere dafür ist es halt nur ausgelegt auch diese zwischenstecker nicht mit
jumper kabel hast du bestimmt zu zahl geurzeiten meistens abends aber so so
richtigen streaming jetzt jetzt geht es noch ich muss es voll auf weiß stellen
dass es richtig warm wird wled limitiert auch den strom ja nee nee nee nur wenn
du die limitierung einschaltest ich habe die limitierung ausgeschaltet kann
nämlich explizites häkchen setzen dass wled nix berechnet sondern einfach volle
pulle macht
oh jetzt ich glaube jetzt habe ich mir gerade finger verbrannt habt ihr es
gesehen warte mal warte mal das war schon 156
oben
habe ich da jetzt auf
youtube please kommen dann halt nicht da gucken wir es uns jetzt nicht an
ok scheiß drauf start jetzt runter easy sechs ne ne ne hab ich kein platz für
ich feife doch ich feife doch fest platz platz technisch auf dem letzten loch
ich hab nur noch 10 g frei egal egal ich glaube ich hab mir da den finger da an der
stelle den finger verbrannt von was da grad gesehen hat andere browser nee das
hat wahrscheinlich mit dem browser überhaupt nichts zu tun kommen ich kann
ja auch anonym machen und so tun als ob da sagt er nope darfst du nicht wird nicht
browser mäßig gemacht sondern wahrscheinlich pro video und wenn es so
oft abgespielt wurde aber es hat schon ein bisschen monat es das ganze und ich
bin ja immer noch am überlegen ob ich das geld für so einen vera fein
mechanik schrauben dreher satz ausgeben soll ich hab ich hab das ich war da
glaube ich in jedem stream bisher drauf und ich habe es mir noch nicht gekauft
ich bin immer noch am überlegen eigentlich hätte ich sehr gerne aber ich
habe eigentlich auf der anderen seite auch welche die sind vollkommen ok das
ist zwar kein vera satz aber die sind in ordnung und warum sollte ich mir was
kaufen wenn ich ja schon was habe
also zu dem hetzener sponsorin bräuchte definitiv noch ein mikrotik und vera
sponsorin so viel wie ich werbung für die macht dann doch lieber eine neue
platte brauche ich auch nicht ich habe in acht terabyte platte drin die habe ich
nur an mal unten wenn ich strieme dass ich nicht aus versehen was liege wer war
beim wer war beim lieg des recording folders alles dabei also so unwahrscheinlich
ist es gar nicht dass man aus versehen sachen liegt die man nicht liegen will
das hat sich der chat natürlich gemerkt das ist mir auch klar
die lex kritiker information hat ja eigentlich gar nichts gesehen
man hat eigentlich gar nichts gesehen aber man weiß ja nie wie twitch policy
ist ich habe es lieber gelöscht das wort
nie gibt es keine clips und wenn es clips gibt lösche ich die clips weil
eventuell tos warum ist denn der so lahm gerade
ja install auf gibt alles kann ich andere videos abspielen
ne darf man nicht ok null ja weißt du was leute leute ich habe heute noch nicht
teures gekauft ich habe noch nichts teures gekauft ich kaufe mir so ein teil
also ich meine ich bestellte nicht on stream weil ich mich einloggen kann aber
scheiß drauf beim ich ich bin schon ich bin die ganze zeit überlegen mir das zu
kaufen aber ich ich sag immer jedes mal ne lohnt sich nicht ich habe ja was und
sonst wie und dann gucke ich das nächste mal wieder weil ich ich bin ich bin schon
seit einem jahr oder so am gucken nach diesem set und ich bin immer wieder kurz
da vor mir das zu kaufen dass es dann bleiben und mal gucken ob das überhaupt
das richtige set es war mal kurz ist das überhaupt das richtige set set was
haben wir dabei 25 stück und wir haben also was haben an kreuz gut brauchen selten
aber gibt noch genug kreuz schlitz umgedreht schlitz mein ich kreuz gibt es
genug schlitz gibt es relativ wenig nur noch aber gibt es gibt es halt noch
welche der schlitz kann man zum hebeln genau so
dann hat man was zum geier was davon ist jetzt talks
das nächste ist talks oder was ist das das brauche ich nette leute das grüne
das brauche ich nicht das set da sind da sind da sind zu viele sachen drinnen
die ich die ich nie im leben die ich nie im leben habe
was ist das auch so gedöns moment kann das sein dass das da gar nicht alles
drin ist was hast du ja kreuz schlitz schlitz schlitz schlitz kreuz talks
jetzt übertreiben sie es aber warum hä warum die gelben die gelben
bavera sind ja da wo man mit dem hammer hinten draufhauen kann aber was ist
denn das für eine kombination fein mechanik und mit dem hammer hinten
draufhauen
das ist aber äußerst komische
nee die elektriker sachen sind eigentlich rot und gelb
ach so das sind tatsächlich die elektriken warum ok dann ist die dann
ist die farbgebung nicht ganz einheitlich weil ansonsten sind die
elektriker sachen immer rot und gelb und gelb sind sind diese dinger zum
hinten draufhauen
na gut vielleicht war einfach kein platz für rot und gelb
ach 673 euro easy ist ja ist ja überhaupt kein problem
man kann man kann man kann es ein wenig übertreiben das set ist übrigens nice
das habe ich das habe ich ich habe anderes ist auch wurscht
gefahrt ich gebe sonst wieder zu viel geld aus ich gebe sonst zu viel geld aus
nee das hat keinen sinn mit bitt halter das habe ich ja schon alles braucht
ehrlich gesagt das wird mir reichen das wird mir wahrscheinlich voll und ganz
ausreichende 23 euro kann man aber machen
gehe auf apple.com warum du meinst wenn ich du meinst wenn ich teure preise sehen
will ja dann gehe ich auf apple.com
apple.com ist ein meck sei hallo will aber kann ein meck die webseite ist
broken die webseite ist ripp also das reicht mir ich glaube das bestelle ich
mal ich muss mich ich mache immer den fehler ich kaufe mir eigentlich immer zu
viel von dem zeug also wenn ich mich dann dazu entschieden habe dass ich mir
kaufen kaufe ich mir meistens immer zu viel genauso wie wenn ich mir teilweise
irgendwie nicht was wollte nicht vier schwach sind ein fünfer oder ein zehner pack
von irgendwelchen kontrollern brauche obwohl ich eigentlich nur ein brauche
also eigentlich wird ein dreier pack voll und ganz reichen einser kaufe ich nie
wisst ihr ja ich kaufe nie einzelne sachen weil gerade bei elektronik sachen
und bei bastler graben geht ja mal ganz schnell eins kaputt und da musste
wieder warten aber drei erreichen eigentlich in der
regel und ich kaufe dann meistens immer fünfer oder zehner total hängen geblieben
ich habe so viel unsinnigen scheiß hier den ich überhaupt nicht brauche also
ja dreier pack controller ja immer eigentlich ist das beste beispielsweise
so was hier zu kaufen aber das braucht ein dreier pack einfach ein dreier pack
fertig kein fünfer kein zehner einfach ein dreier pack dreier pack ist es
eigentlich am besten
also was ist hier was ich bin zwar berufstätiger mediengestalter auch
kannst du gute youtube thumbnails machen ich suche da leute gerade aber ich bin
kurz davor einfach informatik ausbilden zu machen um hier mitreden zu können
wenn ich in einer zukunftsvorstellung so noch mal gefragt werde ob ich damit ja
da hast du vielleicht glück hast du vielleicht glück und du hast auch
leute die hier gucken und du machst bonus punkte
ok mal schauen ob ich irgendwelche questions übersehen habe müssen wir mal
schauen ich habe jetzt pepega board laufen also kde hat wobbly windows
tatsächlich ja ich weiß das habe ich alles schon beantwortet gibt es für die
storage boxen auch ein cli tool ich würde fast vermuten man kann tatsächlich
mit dem hättest du meinst das hättest du ein cli tool ne? ha? cloud?
ich würde vermuten man kann damit auch storage surfer erstellen
ok man kann zum wille mit zepf erstellen
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert
kannst volumes anlegen?
ja keine ahnung so schauen wir mal hier questions
zack hat man da gigabit ablenken ich weiß nicht mehr auf was ich das bezieht
das ist zwei stunden her 0w warum nur für neukunden das weiß ich nicht das
das haben die so entschieden ich vermute mal weil sie halt neukunden gewinnen
wollen hauptsächlich wenn du schon account hast und 400 euro im monat
bezahlt dann sollst du das ja auch gar nichts weitermachen
kannst du die voterfont station empfehlen ich kenne die voterfont station nicht aber
ich kann in der regel selten provider routers empfehlen die fritz boxen sind
allerdings ganz ok aber die unity media box war kacke und die voterfont box ist
auch kacke am besten ist man benutzt die fritz box für decked und voip und
solche sachen und man holt sich einen ordentlichen router plus ein paar
ordentliche access points für die anderen sachen und dann ist gut kostet
ein bisschen mehr aber hat man auch mehr davon ok das habe ich schon alles
beantwortet
das habe ich schon alles beantwortet hier ok
nein habe ich nicht mitbekommen
ne das brauchen wir nicht der chat macht da wieder unsinnige sachen mit wenn die
indito wenn also wenn er wenn der chat irgendwelche dns einträge machen könnte
für eine domain dann hätten wir hätten wir gleich irgendwie jeb cock sub domain
oder sowas am start lego acht monat dankeschön für den zapp big brain
subscription
tja hartes los
habe ich schon gesehen hatte ich schon beantwortet wieso saugst du nicht andere
räume naja das ding steht hauptsächlich im wohnzimmer um den fetten teppich zu
saugen also da liegt ein relativ hoher und staubfänger teppich und ich verwende
den aber auch für andere räume aber die mehr präsentet sich und eben also die
mehr präsentet sich ab und zu wenn den hoch nimmt und umstellt und ich lasse
ihn hauptsächlich im wohnzimmer laufen ich lasse aber auch auf anderen räume im
ersten stock laufen und er ist bis jetzt noch nicht die treppe runtergefallen
habe ich
hatten wir uns schon angeguckt hatten wir uns auch schon angeguckt
wie bezahlt über aliexpress ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher wie ich das letzte
mal bezahlt habe das hängt ja bei aliexpress immer ein bisschen vom
anbieter ab was die akzeptieren ich bin mir relativ sicher dass es anbieter
gibt die paypal akzeptieren
also geht es nicht mehr oder was
genau das kommt nämlich bei aliexpress immer ein bisschen vom hängen ein
bisschen vom händler ab
das heißt im zweifelfall musste mal gucken ob es das produkt bei einem anderen händler gibt
der paypal akzeptiert ansonsten kreditkarte oder ich habe auch noch einen
aliexpress account
ich habe also es war boomer story auszupacken ich benutze den kram ja
schon eine weile ich benutze den schon so lang wo man noch mit aliexpress bezahlen
musste oder bezahlen konnte oder dazu angehalten wurde mit aliexpress zu bezahlen
und aliexpress noch komplett auf chinesisch war da musste ich aliexpress über den
google translator übersetzen dass ich wissen wusste wo ich was eintragen muss
ja das weiß ich nicht deswegen habe ich ihn ja auch nicht bestellt
locker
wie gesagt so mache ich das ja gerade
ja ich habe auch noch einen ifixel also deswegen eigentlich brauche ich das
ganze zeug gar nicht ne
wofür benutzt du die esp boards denn boah ich habe total viele sachen also das
letzte was ich gemacht habe ist wo wir auch ein bisschen programmiert haben war
einmal zum fünf stromzähler im keller und das nächste war für das was habe
ich jetzt im bad hängen für bluetooth sensoren für meine waage und für das
thermostat im bad nicht für das thermostat für das thermometer im bad
ging alles über low energy bluetooth der watt champ genau
ganz immer meine klemmung ist gefühlt ich ja das frage ich mich auch
wahrscheinlich falls wir weil wir es mit internet ausbau und generelle
infrastruktur hier halt nicht haben und ich habe so meine zweifel wenn im
oktober gewählt wird und da wirklich irgendwie mit den grünen was rauskommt
ob das besser wird immer nicht dass die anderen das besser hinkriegen hat man
jetzt die letzten jahre gesehen aber da habe ich noch größere zweifel
dran ob das dann was wird
ja freu mich auch hier wie findest du open sens oder pf sens oder open sens
pf sens muss ich ehrlich sagen habe ich nie großartig lange benutzt pf sens
hatte ich eine ganze weile bestimmt zwei jahre hier im einsatz echt nice auch
relativ gut bedienbar für jemanden nicht so genau durchblick bei der bei der
ganzen geschichte gerade auch das portal für wlan richtig richtig gut finde ich
das kann man kann man empfehlen
hast du irgendwelche ziele dieses jahr ja habe ich ich will endlich 300.000
abos auf youtube haben jetzt ernsthaft guck mal wie lange ich jetzt schon wieder
konstant dabei bin videos zu machen das habe ich das letzte mal vor sieben
jahren gemacht und ich glaube morgen habe ich 285.000 abos also es geht es geht
echt aufwärts ich habe so viele abos wie noch nie auf youtube ich habe in
letzten sechs jahre über ein bisschen was verloren weil ich nichts gemacht
habe aber es geht es geht aufwärts so zwischen 1000 und 3000 im monat es ist
natürlich bei weitem nicht mehr das was ich gemacht habe früher ist ja logisch
wo ich irgendwelche halb call of duty sachen gemacht habe aber du kannst
dich echt nicht beschweren hier im endeffekt 300 bis 600.000 aufrufe
es ist abscribers wunderbar ich streben schon seit vier jahren es kommt mir
echt nicht so lang vor ich komme immer noch wie der größte
ohne scheiß ich komme noch wieder größte kacke stream loop vor ich habe kein
overlay ich habe kein intro ich habe keine gescheiten watz ohne musik ich
habe keine ich habe keine overlays keine anzeigen nix ich habe einfach gar
nix bei meinem stream wenn ich da könnte man sicherlich auch noch richtig viel
geile sachen machen aber mache ich halt nicht weil ich total faul bin was so
was angeht aber mein meins also wie gesagt demnächst gibt es den 3d keks
alle hier noch ein motivationsvideo rickroll wetten wetten das ist ein
rickroll video leute ich ich an ich antizipiere schon ein rickroll video oder
oder oder monka toss video war mir klar voll für blätt klar
das war kein schiebe weil ich habe schon erraten erahnt ja also wie gesagt 300k
will ich haben dieses jahr oder zumindest nahe hinkommen dass ich am
anfang nächsten jahre schaffe aber 300k bis ende des jahres wäre schon cool
ich mache noch ein paar kooperations das bringt immer was und das bringt beiden
seiten was deswegen ist das ganz cool ich plan gerade ein video ich weiß gar
nicht ob ihr ihn kennt ich plan gerade ein video mit wobei ich das nicht in dem
fall ich kann das noch nicht mal schreiben alle nicht für big a big
abo stellt mache in dem fall sondern macht echt gute videos wir wollen ein
video machen zum thema was ist die beste programmier sprache für einsteiger und
jetzt passt mal auf ist ihr müsst ihr müsst jetzt sehr stark sein
also wir haben uns darauf geeinigt wir wir werden wohl javascript nehmen
pyson nehmen go nehmen sie scharp nehmen und er will allen ernstes c++ nehmen aber
er kann er kann in seinem part machen was er will ich ich werde nichts sagen zu
ich werde nichts sagen zu ja aber ihr wisst dass ich kein c++ fern bin
wobei ich glaube er will gar nichts hier plus plus nehme ich glaube er will
eigentlich sagen c und zwar für sachen wo es halt sinnvoll ist falls man mit
aruinus und sowas anfängt dann ist halt eben c c++ ein super einstieg weil es
das einzige ist was du machen kannst so also wenn wir demnächst was zusammen
machen ist auf jeden fall auch ein super channel wenn man sich für diese
thematik hier interessiert also kann man sich durchaus geben und ich hatte
letztens ich habe letztens was unter sein video kommentiert und dann hat
youtube das erst mal gesperrt weil youtube gedacht hat es wäre spam ich
habe unter sein video geschrieben wollen wir nicht demnächst mal was zusammen
aufnehmen oder sowas und es hat youtube erst mal gesperrt weil es gesagt das ist
spam
bitcoin eigentlich habe keine bitcoin ich hätte gerne bitcoin aber nicht
jetzt sondern ich hätte jetzt gerne welche gehabt
hä was der amt champ was latenz wenn man die strecke mit dem was
kann man machen muss dir halt überlegen was du eigentlich vor hast also was
willst du damit bezwecken also was hast du was hast du vor was kannst du jetzt
mit einer aktuellen hardware nicht machen wozu brauchst du es weil ich bin
mittlerweile komplett davon abgekommen sachen zu installieren oder sachen im
einsatz zu haben einfach nur weil es geht wobei ihr wisst dass ich mich
eigentlich selbst gpd mit dieser aussage das stimmt nämlich überhaupt nicht ich
rede mir das immer ein dass ich nur sachen im einsatz habt die sinnvoll sind
und nicht weil es geht aber ich habe sicherlich genug zeugs im einsatz einfach
weil es geht und nicht unbedingt weil es sinnvoll ist
kannst du stonks tipps geben ich kann stonks memes einblenden
zwar es oh was haben wir hier sorry muss wohl mit entwupp los ja muss
ansonsten sehe ich manchmal nicht wachs ich hause an lang deine videos wollte
erst mal danke sagen exzellent hast du deinen wech her gefunden hast
korona attacke gerade gehabt muss ich mich muten
also schau seit langen deine videos also wie gesagt schön dass den wech her
gefunden hast wollte erst mal danke sagen zu dem internet ausbau durfte bis
vor kurzem noch mit dsl ja das ist halt richtig massiver pains camp und bis jetzt
glasfaser und ja nice nice haste glück gehabt ja von der steinzeit in die
zukunft was mich stört ist dass frauen auf gewissen seiten so hochauflösend
dass ich den jeder hat so seinen geschmack ja das ist kein tos das ist
kein tos tos wert ist nur mit bild
das stimmt dafür habe ich das mime bord was eigentlich das allerbeste ist was
ich hier je programmiert habe ich mein wenigstens mal was was sich sinnvoll
verwenden kann ich meine der code ist natürlich unter aller sau aber es
funktioniert ich meine wer hat so was cooles keiner beste beste mime striemen
twitch
so also zack zack
ja ist es ja auch im endeffekt ist es ja auch oder aber da aber ganz ehrlich so
dass das ist für mich auch der gedanke hinter twitch diese ganzen sachen die
aktuell da gerade angesagt sind ist für mich nicht so die nicht so diese an
diese zu der alte twitch gar ist bisschen ist ein bisschen wie bei youtube früher
früher hatte youtube broadcast yourself als motto da sind wir ja auf youtube
mittlerweile komplett weg für mich ist so ist so der alte twitch geist ist zum
beispiel muss ich weiß ich aber dance gaming guckt dance gaming ist der
einzige let's player den ich mir angucken kann und ich fand so die old
school twitch zeit irgendwie cooler man muss halt mal sagen in professionelle
richtung hat sich das mit amazon schon also umgedreht hat sich seit aber seit
der amazon übernahme schon in deutlich professionellere richtung
entwickelt ja auch mit den möglichkeiten gerade durch die ganzen
prime subs und sowas ist schon gut es wird ja aktuell total schlecht gerät
insgesamt ist die plattform wahrscheinlich attraktiver als jemals
zuvor aber trotzdem so die so die so die old school vibes ja oder der forsen
chat oder sowas ich habe am anfang auch gerne exquisite geguckt aber mittlerweile
kann ich mir das nicht mehr geben weil es ist also erstens macht der konter
nämlich nicht mehr interessiert und der chat ist mittlerweile so krass folge
spammt und sinnlos dass da gar nichts mehr geht ja sehe ich auch so
ab ab wir haben ja wirklich leute mit komischen vorlieben sagt kann das
pepegabot dark mode sein nur mit add-on ich habe glaube kein dark reader add-on
pepegabot kann nur mit add-on dark reader sein was hältst du von bitcoin oder kann
ich das muss ich jetzt zu weit ausholen da muss ich jetzt zu weit ausholen und
ihr wisst boomer schlafen gleich kann ich jetzt können wir uns im nächsten
stream was kann ich was zu sein so was sag mal hast du bestimmt ahnung von
hardwares geht ehrlich gesagt nicht ich habe immer nur ahnung von hardware wenn
ich mir was kaufen will ist meine frage dass ich bei meinem pc abgräben es ist
gerade eine schlechte zeit hardware zu kaufen
ach moment geht um einen lautsprecher ich will mir neue 5 und 1 box für den pc
kaufen und da brauche ich doch bestimmt auch eine gute soundkarte oder nee kann
ich dir nichts empfehlen wobei willst du das zum videos gucken oder
zum spielen also 5.1 boxen zum spielen kann man sicherlich machen wenn der
raum groß genug ist aber ich persönlich bevorzuge ja ganz normale stereo
kopfhörer und virtuelle surround aber nee ich kann dir keine soundkarte
empfehlen kenne mich nicht mit aus gerade bei solchen wahnsinn sachen ich habe
mein audio interface hier kopfhörer dran fertig das meme board nein kann ich
nicht kann ich nicht und dass das meme board ist ist open source aber nur eine
uraltversion den rest habe ich noch nicht hochgeladen werde ich wahrscheinlich
auch nicht weil da muss mich auch schämen für aber die memes gibt es alle
irgendwie über google oder sonst wie oder manche hat manche zum beispiel der
den hat irgendein mod ich glaube dass sie das max war das damals sogar hat den
erstellt für den stream ich finde es lustig wird es die leute immer probieren
aber es funktioniert nicht
als ich bin dumm gewesen ich habe meinen 64 und meine wege
geschmissen beim umziehen aber die spiele habe ich behalten lustigerweise
vom end 64
die standardfirmen wir als vollkommen in ordnung
das kosten eigentlich in 64 gerade wenn ich mir einkaufen will in schwarz ja ich
glaube die gab es nur mit schwarz oder nee die gab es glaube auch in anderen
farben 50 euro vielleicht sollte ich mir noch mit 64 kauen man gibt es dann
wieder z plus plus stellt so lange ich es vermeiden kann gibt es das nie
na gucke mal hier für 65 euro und 64 mit vier controller vom spielerpapa
200 euro um ist es so ultra teuer
ach so weil es gebraucht ist aber die anderen sind bestimmt auch gebraucht
das würde die sachen zu emulieren ist kein ding ja aber so eine echte konsole
hätte ich hab ja die spiele hier noch also wäre eigentlich schon cool wenn ich
mir wieder einholen würde ich bin mir nicht sicher ob die nicht auf github
ihren kram haben
anscheinend nicht in der ganzen mittags motor flaschen das geht auch das motor
läuft da eins zu eins out of the box drauf ganz ehrlich die sachen spielten
am ende doch ähnlich kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen ich ich könnte mich da
schon sehen bis in 64 spielen
jepp hab nur ich ich bin der einzige jepp hat als emote der chat kriegt kein jepp
war nix dankeschön für die vier monate subscription glaube ich habe eben noch
jemanden übersehen wartet mal ich guck mal kurz
real mags dankeschön trein vor drei minuten und primes ab poggers max
headroom prime subscription vor 13 minuten dankeschön
und das sebex und lego auch noch hier du schaffst wieder die hälfte übersehen
hier ebay klein anzeigen war das letzte preis habe ich kein bock drauf
keine ahnung wahrscheinlich ist irgendwelche microcontroller mit
irgendwelche sachen die mit c programmiert werden gehe ich mal von
aus oder windows 95 was kann ohne miss kann tatsächlich sein
kennst du leute die nur open source software benutzen und vorher den kaut
ist ehrlich gesagt nicht ich kenne ein paar so richtig krasse open source
hardware fanatiker hat nicht hardware hardcore fanatiker aber selbst die lesen
nicht jeden korn für den sie also ich kenne beispielsweise auch niemand mehr
der gente benutzt ich ich hatte mal ein kollege der hat gente benutzt er hat
zwei tage gebraucht bis er sein notebook in betrieb nehmen konnte weil er den
netzwerk treiber irgendwie 20 mal kompilieren wusste bis die netzwerkkarte
funktioniert aber ich kenne keinen mehr der gente benutzt
ich benutze übrigens artsch falls euch das interessiert
by the way
guckst du semper videos die streams gucke ich nicht ich habe ihn ein paar mal gehostet
aber die videos gucke ich öfters mal ja
moin jetzt im friseur im friseur jetzt gut
was ist denn der dc im friseur jetzt gut wenn ich frage was der friseur macht der
friseur kreisel grinded in mmo 8 ein halb stunden am tag im kreis mit
webcam im vergleich zu mir aber bald gibt es die kicks cam
auf discord der gendu benutzen will ja es gibt leute die können es nicht sein
lassen
ok leute ich muss jetzt pennen 22 morgen wieder arbeiten
wir sehen uns bis denn aber wir brauchen outro musik oder vielleicht vielleicht
haben irgendjemand kleineres dem ich folgen der den host gebrauchen kann
komm mal semper videos am start
rain rain was semper video obs falsches chat fenster rain was semper video und
spam spam eine runde keine ahnung wupp gassen also bis denn macht es gut wir
sehen uns zu spam mag er nicht ja muss er jetzt durch ist der end macht es gut